foreign
welcome to this video tutorial on python
data analysis project for 2022. in this
video we'll be covering two interesting
Hands-On projects using Python
Programming you will learn how to use
real world data to perform data analysis
and data visualization the two projects
are based on coronavirus and Olympics
data you will learn to collect analyze
clean manipulate and visualize data with
the help of python libraries such as
numpy pandas matplotlib and c-bond these
two projects will give you the idea to
solve real world problems using
exploratory data analysis so let's get
started with our first project
today we are going to perform two
Hands-On projects on covet data analysis
using Python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where I'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you kovit or
Corona virus is an ongoing Global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in Wuhan China
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as SARS cove2
on March 11 2020 the who declared
covid-19 a global Health Emergency the
virus has so far infected over 22 crore
people and killed more than 4.5 million
Innocents in India there have been over
3.3 crore confirmed cases and nearly 4
lakh 41 000 deaths have been reported so
far
this data is according to official
figures released by The Union Ministry
of Health and Family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does Corona in coronavirus mean
here are the options is it a beer
B respiratory is it C crown or is it d
sun this is a very generic question I am
sure a lot of you may already know some
of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use three
different covid-19 data sets and perform
data analysis using Python and tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and raw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in Tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases that's reported
the number of recoveries as well as
Active cases
we will also see how India has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covid-19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using so for our first
project using python we'll be using the
first two data sets covid-19 India and
covet vaccine statewise let me open the
two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date we have the time
then we have the different state names
but scroll down you can see we have
Kerala Tamil Nadu Delhi haryana
Rajasthan ladakh Punjab
Telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed Indian national so actually
this two data sets confirmed Indian
national and confirmed foreign National
we won't be using so in the demo itself
we'll be dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the total number of confirmed
cases
let me just
sort the B column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
I'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here this is
till
11th of August 2021
so this data was collected from Kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free we will provide the link to the
datasets in the description of the video
so please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before I jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine statewise is my
second data set
let me open it there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python project you can
see we have a column called updated on
then we have the state again you can see
here there are a few discrepancies here
uh
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered we
have the sessions sites first dose
administered then we have the second
dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different vaccines
Shield you have Sputnik V
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
Hands-On part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers is it a
Japan B Israel C Portugal or is it D
Cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch Daily News
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comment section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so I am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
Python jupyter notebook I'll just rename
this notebook as
covid
data analysis
project
I click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first I am importing pandas SPD this is
for
data manipulation then we have numpy as
NP numpy is used for numerical
computation then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly these three
libraries will be used for plotting our
data and creating interesting
visualizations finally I am also
importing
my date time
function
all right
so I'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the covid-19 cases in India for the
different states and union territories
so I'll create a variable called covet
underscore DF DF is for data frame
I'll use my pandas Library
and then
give the read underscore CSV function
since a data sets are CSV files and
inside double quotes I'll pass in the
location where my data sets are present
so I'll just copy this location
I'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that I'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
as a coved 19
India dot CSV
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few rows of the data
frame I am going to use the head
function
I'll say head and within brackets let's
see I'll
pass in 10 which means I want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if I run it there you go
here you can see from 0 till 9 so we
have 10 rows of information and these
are the different
column names you have S number
date time state or Union territory then
you have confirmed International
confirmed foreign National cured cases
deaths reported and the confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead let's use the info
function to get some idea about
a data set
if I run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns the total number of entries or
the rows we have 18 110 rows of
information starting from 0 till 18109
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that I'll be using the describe function
okay so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75 percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set which is related to
vaccination
so I'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore DF
I'll write PD Dot
read underscore CSV function which is
present in pandas
Library I'll move to the top and I'll
copy the
file location and we'll change the name
of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covet underscore 19
underscore India
I'm going to say covid
underscore
vaccine
underscore statewise
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
statewise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
I'll be using the head function and
inside the function I'll pass in 7.
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covet underscore DF data frame we'll be
dropping a few unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed Indian national and conformed
foreign National as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better to learn how to drop the columns
for our analysis
so I'll say
covid underscore DF
Dot
I'll use the drop function
and within square brackets I'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
we'll give a comma
within double quotes I'll see the next
column is time
my third column that I want to drop is
confirmed
Indian national
give another comma
within double quotes I'll say
confirmed
foreign National
outside the
square brackets I'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to I'll say true
we'll give another comma and say
axis equal to 1.
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed Indian okay it should be
Indian national and not Indian Nation
I'll just
mention it as National we'll run it
again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
Union territory cured that's and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to date time
I'll say covet underscore DF
I'll pass in my column name that is date
I'll say equal to
PD Dot
I'll use the pandas function that is 2
underscore
date time
I'll say covid underscore DF which is my
data frame name
pass in my variable which is date
give a comma
and I'll use my argument that is format
equal to
I'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage m
you have another Dash and say percentage
d
let's run it
and I'll print
the head of the data frame
cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to find the total
number of active cases so active case is
nothing but the total number of
confirmed cases minus the sum of cure
cases plus deaths reported
so let's
find the Active cases I'll give a
comment
okay
I'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
I'll say equal to
covet underscore DF
and My First Column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
I'll say
covet underscore DF
then I'll pass in my cured column
Plus
I'll again say
covid
underscore DF
and add my
death column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
it
says data frame object has no attribute
Tails this should be deal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called Active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and deaths reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas Library so in
this table we'll be summing all the
confirmed deaths and cured cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
I'll create a variable called statewise
and say PD Dot
I'll use the pivot underscore table
function
I'll pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore DF
and then
we'll give my
values parameter inside the square
brackets I'll pass in my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cured column
you give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
I'll say Union territory
I will
give a comma Now
and pass in my last argument which is
AGG
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be Max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
I'm going to find out the recovery read
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of cured cases divided
by the total number of confirmed cases
into hundred
so I'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets I'll
pass in my variable that I want to
create which is recovery rate
this will be equal to
the
cured cases
multiplied by hundred
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets I'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
I'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so I am just going to
replace the names here I'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured I'll say
my deaths column
into 100 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it okay
now
we are going to
sort the values based on the confirmed
cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it I'll say
statewise equal to
I'll use the function short underscore
values
so
we'll pass in my variable statewise Dot
and use the
short underscore
values function I'll say bye
I want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and I'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that I'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
I'll show you how to do it
says style Dot
background
underscore gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap so cmap stands for
color Maps this is present inside the
matplotlib Library so here you can see
there is a nice documentation on
choosing color maps in matplotlib this
is provided by matplotlib.org
if I scroll down you can see there are a
number of c maps that you can use
purples Blues you have something called
Reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter cool
all these you can use whichever color
map that you want and here you can see
the different
sheets
or the gradients
okay
so I am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as I said in the beginning there are
a few discrepancies in the data set so
here you can see
this one called Maharashtra and there is
also Maharashtra Triple Star
this you can ignore even if I scroll
down you have madhya Pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for Bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data sees that Maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
Kerala Karnataka Tamil Nadu Andhra
Pradesh and uttar Pradesh so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases even if you see the
mortality rate is also high for
Maharashtra
and
if I scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if I scroll further your Punjab the
mortality rate is also High
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
Kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
Active cases
so we'll start
I'll give a comment top 10
active
cases States
okay
so we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as Group by
so I'll first
in my data frame which is covered
underscore DF
dot followed by the group by function
I am going to group my data based on
state slash
Union territory column
then I'll say
Dot
Max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
Active cases so I have passed in my
Active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we are going to sort the values so I'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
I'll say shot by
column that is
Active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
I'll give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that I'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
I have
missed a square bracket here let me give
a rather square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay that is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now I'll create another variable called
fij
here we will pass in
the PLT which is for matplotlib library
and will give the
figure size
using the
fixed size
argument
is equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title will pass in the title
let's say top 10 states
with
most
Active cases in India
I'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x axis and the y-axis
I'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis I am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c bond Library
I'll say sns.bar plot
I'll say data equal to
my variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
States
this is actually active States
all right
and now
I'm going to use the
ilock function
and take the first 10 states so I'm
using a colon and then giving 10 as my
value iloc is for index location
I'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
Active cases
give another comma and say my x axis to
be
state
slash
Union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
I'll say line width equal to 2 and will
give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so I have my
access defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active States not found
let's go to the stop and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 Active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x-axis also has a mistake this
should be state slash Union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot created but as you can see here the
labels of the different states and union
territories are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
X labels I'll say plt.x
label
and my
X label would be States
then I'll say PLT Dot
by label
my y label will have the total
Active cases
and finally I'll write PLT dot show
before I run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
India into one cell
so what I'll do is I'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
I'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and will
paste it here
next let's take the
title and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and I'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice bar plot ready on the top
you can see the title top 10 states with
most active cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala
we also have Andhra Pradesh Gujarat West
Bengal and chattisgarh so as you can see
Maharashtra has the highest number of
active cases based on our data followed
by Karnataka Caroline Tamil Nadu at
second third and fourth please
respectively and in the ninth place we
have West Bengal in the 10th place we
have chhattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
Active cases
which are in Lacks
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
debts reported
so I'll give a comment
top states with
highest
debts
okay
so I'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of Active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so I'll start with my
data frame that is covered underscore DF
followed by using the group by function
and I want to group my data
based on
the state slash
Union territory column
then I'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets I'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent I'll be using
single quotes
okay
I'll say dot
gonna
short my
result therefore I'm using the sort
underscore values function I want to
sort it by
death column
I'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means I
want to
order my result in
descending order
then I'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that I'll give my
figure size I'll say PLT dot figure
and within brackets I'll pass in my
argument which is
fixed size
equal to
using a tuple I'll say 18 comma let's
say five
now let's give a title for that I'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
I'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels we'll just scroll down
okay
so I'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so I'm
using my c bond Library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore depths which is
this variable
I'll give
my index location iloc
I'm going to choose
12 States the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
I'll show you once I plot this result
so in the y axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x axis we'll take
state
slash
Union territory
okay
I'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and we'll give an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so I'll say Edge color equal to let's
say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the X label the Y label
so I'll say PLT dot X label
X label would be States
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then I'll write PLT dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths now what I
specifically wanted you to see was these
discrepancies in the data you can see
here Maharashtra is repeated twice even
in our data that we collected from Kegel
Karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where Karnataka is
spelled as
k-e-r-e-a-n instead of k-a-r-n-a all
right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results I had given my index location
till 12 so we have Maharashtra Karnataka
Tamil Nadu Dali then uttar Pradesh West
Bengal Kerala Punjab Andhra Pradesh and
satiskar
with the states that have the most
number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the growth or the trend of Active cases
for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
Maharashtra Karnataka Kerala Tamil Nadu
and uttar Pradesh I can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
I'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
PLT dot figure
I'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6.
I'll say
my axis as SNS Dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
my original data frame that is covid
underscore DF
and
within square brackets I'll say covid
underscore DF
and we are going to pass in the
State or the Union
territory column
I'll give
a DOT and use the is in function
so the States should include
Maharashtra
will give a comma the next state should
be
Karnataka
next
we have
Kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is Tamil Nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be uttar
Pradesh
all right
so I'll give
a comma here and then say x equal to
the date column
y will be
Active cases column
and I'm going to use another parameter
called Hue which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so hue
will be my
state slash
Union territory column
okay
after this
I'll see
ex Dot set title
my title will be top five
affected States
in India
will give a size let's say
16.
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16 and make sure everything is fine
let me just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
DF
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again all right
if I scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in India
you see the different
States here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
Maharashtra you can see how the Active
cases
searched around
April and May
and then you can see even for Karnataka
the Active cases surged very rapidly
around me
and June
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar Pradesh
as well as for Tamil Nadu so all the
five states you can see one common Trend
that after March so around April
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and later after July they started
dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the D's you would have vaccination
for people
and
very crucial error that we are going to
deal with is this state column here you
can see
in the state column we have India in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename
are updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
a rename function present in the pandash
library to do it so I'll say vaccine
underscore DF Dot
rename
I'll say columns equal to
Within
curly braces
I'll write
updated
on
Which is my
original column name
give a colon I want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
I'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date in the
original data frame
let's run it
now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set you can see here we have
successfully changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can check
the
total number of columns rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries and these are the
columns that are present
and if I scroll further
you see here
says
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so I'll say vaccine underscore DF dot is
null
and then I'm going to use the sum
function over it
Fair on it
there you go
so almost all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
meal individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the each groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns so I'll say
a new variable called vaccination
I'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore DF and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
I'll pass in the
column names that I want to drop
I'll say
who doses
administered
so this is the column that I want to
delete Sputnik V doses administered
I'll give a comma
the second column is e e f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
has deuces
administered
give a comma
I'll say 45 to 60
years
doses
administered
to another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
deuces
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally I'll give my parameter axis
equal to 1.
okay let me just recheck this
column names first one is Sputnik V
doses administer then we have
EFI
followed by 18 to 44 years dose is
administered then we have 45 to 60 years
doses administered
finally we have 60 plus years
I've added
s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well because
there's a space here in the column now
let's run it all right
so we have successfully dropped
The Columns that we wanted to drop
now I'll see vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now
we are going to create a
plot
that is a pi plot to see
the vaccination for me land
female individuals so I'll give a
comment
as male verses
female vaccination
to create this pipe plot I am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one broadly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
meal individuals
from our data frame
I'll say meal equal to
vaccination
meal
I'll passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here mail
individuals vaccinated
then I'll say dot sum
similarly we'll filter out the female
individuals
I'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets I'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
I'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool
now I am going to say PX
dot Pi function which is present in the
plotly library
I am going to
Give the names of the
pies
so first one is mail
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values equal to
mil comma
female
then I'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
meal and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
so it'll take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here I have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value so from our data you can see 53
percent meal
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for female
okay now we are going to drop all those
rows where
our state was mentioned as India in the
original data set
I had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows where
state is India
okay
so to do that I'll say
vaccine I'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
which is vaccine underscore DF
I'll say
vaccine underscore
DF Dot
state
not equal to
India
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values or
the rows where state is not equal to
India
cool
now what we are going to do is
we'll rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so I'll say vaccine Dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
Within
curly braces I'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon and we'll change this to
just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally I'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if I scroll to the
right and if I check
we have successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this I'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
VSC which is for maximum vaccination
I'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
I want to grip it by State column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
and convert this to frame
there should be a DOT
two underscore frame
and I'll pass in my column name which is
total
foreign BAC
equal to
Max underscore vac Dot
shot
underscore values
I'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means I want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of individuals vaccinated
I want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see we have Maharashtra
uttar Pradesh Rajasthan Gujarat and West
Bengal as the top five states with most
number of vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use the stable and
convert it into a
chart
now I had already written my code for
the bar plot I'm just going to paste it
so here I have defined my figure size as
10 comma 5
then I am giving a title as top 5
vaccinated states in India and the size
is 20 after that I have created a
variable called X
which is going to store my bar plot this
part plot we have created using the c
bond Library
and
you see here I have my
y-axis defined then I have the line
width and the edge color as well
I have given my X label as States viable
as vaccination and I'm finally going to
display my plot so let's go ahead and
run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this table into a bar
plot now
so first we have Maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccinations
then we have uttar Pradesh Rajasthan
Gujarat and West Bengal
now
I want
the viewers watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in India
which means the states which have least
number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your quotes
in the comment section of the video it
will be very similar to these two cells
just that now we want to know the least
five vaccinated states in India
so please put the code Snippets in the
comment section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it will
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right so this brings us to the end
of the first project on Kobe data
analysis using python
so in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the covid-19 India data set for
different states and union territories
and the second data set that we used was
for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in India
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our Tableau
project let's see the final quiz
which of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct covet
symptoms here are the options is it a
fever B visual loss C loss of taste and
smell or is it t cuff
please put your answers in the comment
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we'll move on to our second covet
data analysis project for this project
we'll be using the Tableau Software and
a global coronavirus data set
first we look at the data set and the
fields we have
okay so I am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our python project this time we
are going to use the global covet data
let me open it
all right so here you can see we have
the different country names there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries then we have a
column called last updated so here you
can see our data is still
12th of March 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people tested
then we have a column called
Active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries then we have the mortality
rate this is in fractions
then we have the number of recovered
cases and finally we have a column
called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths and the recovered cases
column
and we'll be using the Tableau Software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
I'll search for Tableau public you can
see here I have Tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of Tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see I have created a few
visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our CSV data set to Tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
I'm going to use text file
and under Chrome download so I'll search
for my folder covered
Dash India and here I have my Global
code data file let me open it
this will take some time to load
now you can see
so on the Tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirm
deaths mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a region or a geographic field
ABC means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abcr text field and this hash represents
numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data let
me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to
create our different reports all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data Pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the name of
the data set Global covet data and here
you can see the different columns that
we have in the data set so on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions and at the
bottom whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures so dimensions are always
represented with blue icons and measures
are in green icons
so
Tableau has automatically detected the
different data types for each of the
columns
all right
so first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that I am going to drag my
country or the region column onto rows
here you have rows I'll just drag it and
drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from Afghanistan
till Zimbabwe so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country I am going to drag my confirmed
column onto text so here under marks
card you have the text option I'll just
drag it and drop it here
there you go
so Tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
I told you this data was till March 2021
cool
now you can go ahead and
shot the table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region there you go so here you can
see these are the countries which have
very few cases
and if I scroll down
you have France UK Russia Brazil India
and us with the highest number of kobit
19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this simple table
into different charts and graphs to do
that here on the right top corner you
have an option called show me
now
I can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and short the
data
there you go so here you have us India
Brazil Russia UK France Spain and Italy
this is a horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select These Bars
so I'll select till let's say
Germany
or let's see till Argentina
okay and I'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases I'll
just click on keep only
there you go
so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases now you can go
ahead and
play with the color formatting so here
under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can Mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so Tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove Argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
okay you see here Argentina has been
removed I've click on undo so Ctrl Z to
get it back cool now you can convert
this horizontal bar plot into a vertical
bar plot let me show you how to do it
I'll just remove these fields from my
chart now what I'm going to do is I'll
drag country or region onto columns and
I'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have a
vertical bar plot now and again you can
use the axis now to short your data this
isn't
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to sort your data
okay
cool
and Below you can see the
different country names
all right
now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet let's say
top 10.
confirmed
countries
the supply
and click on OK you have the title to
this plot similarly you can change it
here as well top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first I'll drag my
longitude generated
field onto columns and then I'll drag
latitude onto rows
you see here we have the map ready
and now
I'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you the different
country names you can see here we have
Canada
the United States
Mexico
here you have India Sri Lanka there's
Australia this is Brazil and similarly
we have Spain France Belgium
there's
Italy here we have also Greece
similarly we have the African countries
like
Central African Angola
and on the top you have Russia and this
is Iceland so on and so forth
now
I am going to drag
the Active cases column onto
detail again
now if I hover the cursor you can see
the active numbers for Brazil you can
see for India
you have
countries like China
then here you have Thailand
Algeria
now
I'm going to drag the confirmed cases
column onto label so that you have the
labels here you can see here the
confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose for Europe you want to focus on
this region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the Active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see I'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and confirmed cases
I'll rename the title to
global
cases
I'll just click on apply and ok
similarly I'll change the sheet name as
well to
Global cases
okay now from this map you can see the
countries such as USA
Brazil
you have Russia
and India with the highest number of
covid-19 cases even in countries such as
Spain the numbers are really high
and a lot of the African countries were
also impacted
and these small countries like Solomon
Islands you have
fizzy islands with few number of cases
even for New Zealand as well
all right
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest deaths have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we'll create a tree map now
so first of all I'll
choose my country column and
put it under columns and then I'll
select the deaths column and put it
under rows
I have the
bar plot ready
next I'll go to show me and here I have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so I'll just click on the
Stream app
okay here you can see I have my tree map
ready so Tableau has automatically
adjusted my Fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under size color and
label
next I will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
I am going to choose top
I'll filter by field I'm going to select
the top 10
countries based on the total number of
deaths just click on apply and click on
OK
so these are the countries us Brazil
Mexico India United Kingdom Italy Russia
Spain France Germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now you can also
give the label
I'll put the deaths column under label
so that you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
I'll just
change the title top 10
deaths
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's I'll keep it Tableau bold
and I'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and ok
there you go
similarly let's rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving to the next visualization
where we'll see about the recoveries
so before we move on to create a
visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the Stream app
so here
by default Tableau select the automatic
palette if you want you can change it to
different
palette let's see I'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and I'll click on OK
if this is
not looking
that grid you can select another one
let's see
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
I'll click on apply and ok
first I'll drag my country or the region
column under columns
and then I'll take
the recovered column under rows this
time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
I'll select
my bagged
bubble chart
after that I am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then I'll also put country under
filters
so I'll go to
the top
menu and I'll filter it by field I want
to show the top 10 countries based on
the average number of recoveries
if we click on apply and ok you can see
here these are the countries that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have India Brazil
turkey Italy Argentina Germany Colombia
Russia Poland and Mexico
I'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay so here we are going to create a
scatter plot to analyze the total
confirmed cases versus the total number
of deaths so whenever you have two
numeric Fields it is better to create a
scatter plot to visualize the
cases so for that I am going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then I'll drag my
deaths column onto rows
okay
so by default the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries I am going to
drag country under color
I'll see at all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend
for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of deaths
as per our data set then you also have
Brazil here which has the second highest
number of deaths
then you have
Mexico followed by India so this data is
not a very recent data this data was
last updated on March
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the debts
so for that I'll drag my country column
onto filters
and I'll go to top
filter by field
I'll say top 10 and I'll click on apply
and ok
so here you can see we have Siberia
Sweden
Belgium Netherlands Spain
Italy France Russia UK and
you have Brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
Active cases so instead of active let's
select debts click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
Brazil India
then Mexico
UK Russia France Italy Germany and Spain
which have the highest number of deaths
reported so far
now if you want you can change
the size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so I can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spin France UK have the highest number
of active cases
now let's say instead of active I'll
just have my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
Circle to any other shape let's say
square or this Asterix
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
I'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
deaths click on apply and okay
I'll rename this to
confirmed
versus deaths
all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first I'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then I'll have
my country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order so you can see here you
have Yemen there is Mexico Syria Sudan
Egypt equator China and other countries
which have the highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the color
stop automatic let's select summer or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
Tableau classic medium I'll assign this
palette yes I'll apply and okay
all right
finally
will
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the Dual axis chart in Tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have one column and on the right also
you'll have one column with the role
axis values
so this dual access chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases let me show you how to do it
so I'll drag my country
field onto
columns
and then
I'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here I have got my
line chart
and the second
column I'm going to choose is the deaths
column
I'll hold my cursor and I'll place it
when I get this
green color rectangle I'll place it here
there you go so now we have created two
measure names that's and recovered
and here you have the access values
you can synchronize the access values if
you want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the deaths are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change the
recovered line two
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue
I'll assign the palette click on apply
and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
deaths from Blue to let's say
winter I'll assign the palette click on
apply and ok
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the axis same you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize access
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
I'll rename this sheet to
dual axis
okay now before we move ahead and create
our final dashboard I want to show you
one more
feature in Tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh thirty
thousand eight hundred and twenty one we
can change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what I'll do is I'll go to format and
here we have the option to select
font
and in font I'll go to fields and click
on sum of deaths
and here
in this pane I'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be zero
and
display units I'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k so on and so
forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so I'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that it fits our
View
so we have selected the default view and
the size I am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the
Global cases sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
I'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so Tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet at the right
location
okay
and now I choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths and if you want you can choose
any one of
these let's say I'll take the Dual
access chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still go
ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different filters to it
we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here to unknown four nulls you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
there you go so this is our final
dashboard that we have created all right
so this brings us to the end of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
Tableau public
platform under your profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on Kobe data analysis
project using Python and Tableau welcome
to this exciting video on Olympics
dataset analysis using python by simply
learn this is going to be a very
interesting and interactive session
where I'll give you a brief about the
history of Olympics and throw some light
into the recently held Tokyo Olympics
but we'll focus more on using Olympics
data set that is available on Kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in Python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion I'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the Olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin
the Olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet it is held
every four years the first modern
Olympics took place in Athens Greece in
1896. as per National Geographic
the original Olympics took place in 776
BC
so they began as part of an ancient
Greek festival with celebrated Jews the
Greek god of sky and weather
the Rings in the Olympics logo represent
the five continents Europe Africa Asia
the Americas and ushinia
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
Summer Olympics took place in the same
year but now they alternate every two
years
before I move on here is an interesting
question for you only two people have
ever won gold medals at both the summer
and the Winter Olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the Summer Olympics in Tokyo began on
the 23rd of July and recently concluded
on the 8th of August
we got to witness some Thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well winning and losing a
part and parcel of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see This Global event happened this
year Following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our Olympic fever High let's take
this opportunity to work around the
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past Olympics data and answer
specific questions in this video we'll
be using specific python libraries such
as numpy pandas matplotlip and c-bond to
make sense of our data and extract
meaningful information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before I show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis I have
another general question for you
which is the first Olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
Olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the ear and the city name where the
Olympics was held in the comment section
of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video so here you can see I have my
Olympic data set folder that has two
data sets these are CSV files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called NOC underscore
regions so we'll be using these two data
sets these data sets can be downloaded
from Kegel we will post the data set
links in the description of the video
please go ahead and download them these
data sets have been directly taken from
the internet
now I'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events so
I have
around 15 columns you can see the count
here and there are nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use the other data set we are
going
to use in this demo is called NOC
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is NOC stands for National Olympic
Committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the Olympic Committee
we have the region name so afg is for
Afghanistan you have elb for Albania elg
for Algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the region for example here
antiqua is actually antiqua and Barbuda
all right
let's move to the first data set that I
showed you this is our primary data set
for our demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains nearly 2 lakh 71 116
rows of information and there are 15
columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
Olympic event
so here ID is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or F for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms we have the team
name these are the country names you
have China Denmark Netherland there are
around 200 country names
then we have the NOC as I said NOC is a
three letter code that stands for
National Olympic Committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the Winter
Olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the ear column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or Winter Olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host City
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball Judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for Speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal be it gold
silver branch and any means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for ad
analysis so I'll take you to my Jupiter
notebook right away
I have opened it on Chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here Olympics data set
analysis I have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use numpy pandas
matplotlibbon c-bond let me hit shift
enter to import all the
libraries
all right now the next thing is to load
the data sets
using pandas read underscore CSV
function
so
I'll create a variable called athletes
I'll say equal to
PD dot I'll use the read underscore CSV
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so I'll copy this location
and here I'll paste make sure this is
within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
give another forward slash and after
that I'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
events
dot CSV
I'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will load the second data
set I'll create another variable called
regions
so it will have my data frame
I'll use the same function PD dot read
underscore CSV
I'll just copy this
file path till here
we'll paste it
and
I'll give my second file name which is
NOC underscore
regions dot CSV you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second word is NOC underscore
regions
okay I'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error I
think this is Regions
cool
now moving ahead let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
I'll use the head function for that
I'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set athletes you can see
here
from 0 to 4 you have five rows of
information the ID name sex or the
gender each height feet
if I go to the right you have games your
season sport event and medal
now let's see the
second data set that we
imported or loaded I'll see regions dot
head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay I have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have NOC region and some
notes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
I'll create a variable
called athletes underscore TF
then
I'll use my first variable which is
athletes
I'll say dot merge which is my function
name
I'm going to merge
the regions data frame
I'll use the how parameter
in how I'll give my value as I want to
do a left join
and my common column in both the
datasets is actually NOC
so I'm going to use
the NOC column as my common column to
merge both the data sets now let's go
ahead and
print the
merged data frame I'll say athletes
underscore DF dot head let's run it
there you go
so if you see clearly if I move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
First Data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with the lowercase
letter so we'll use
the rename function to
meet the column names consistent
but before that
let's
see the shape of the data frame so I'll
print the shape of the data frame to
know the total number of rows and
columns I'll say
athletes if I hit tab
you will see it will give me
The Prompt I'll select athletes
underscore DF
I'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had 15
columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so I'll show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF
dot I'll use the rename function
and then I'll say
columns
equal to
I'll use curly braces
My First Column that is region I want to
change it to
region but the r should be Capital now
or uppercase
give a comma
and then see
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes I want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
I'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
we'll give a comma here and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athletes underscore DF data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function I'll run this again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
I'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types non-null values and
memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so I'll write
athletes underscore DF
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have 2 lakhs
7116 rows or entries
then you have the
different column names and
you see it says non-null and the data
type of the column below you can see
some information about the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types so let me show
you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical summary
I'll just write describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if I scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns so
here you can see we have the total count
the mean of each of these columns you
have the standard deviation the minimum
and maximum value and then we have the
25th percentile the 15th percentile and
the 75th percentile value of the columns
ID age height written here
all right now one thing to notice here
is if you see the year column the
minimum year is
1896 so this is when
Olympics started and until recently
the Rio Olympics that was held in 2016.
all right now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in The Columns of the
data set
so first I am going to create
a variable called
Nan values
give equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF and the function
to check is I'll say is any
I'll create another
variable called any and underscore
columns
and here I'll use the any function I'll
say Nan underscore this
variable which is underscore values
dot I'll see any
and I'll print my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
Boolean values so if there are any null
or any n or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you Mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values we have
each height weight middle region and
notes columns that have
missing values so hence it has given us
true the rest of the columns do not have
any any n or missing values hence they
are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so I'll say
athletes
underscore DF dot I'll use the function
is null and again I'll use this sum
function
okay this should be is null
if I run it you can see it here
so while each column has 9474
rows where we have null values
then we have some null values for the
height column as well for the weight
column so these are the total number of
rows where we don't have any information
regarding each height weight or region
notes this middle is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in Olympics
don't win any medals so for them the
value is an a now before I move ahead
I have a question for you people so the
question is I want you to print the
column names containing null values or
missing values in the form of a list
so please answer this question and put
it in the comment section of the video
we would be happy to know your approach
so the question I'll repeat it again I
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list so
basically on the top we saw there were
six columns that had null values I want
you to print these six columns in the
form of a list
all right now moving ahead now let's see
the data for specific countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the Olympic
Games from the beginning for India
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it I'll see
athletes underscore DF Dot
we'll use the query function
and then
I'll say team which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value I'll give us India
now let's display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from India if I run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within single quote I'll just delete
this single code from here and we'll add
it in the end
now let's run it there you go
so here you can see we have
the top five rows of
the athletes who are from India you can
see here the region is India you can see
the nocs India the team is India and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete the sex each so for
each you have some missing values you
have the wheat team here and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for Japan
let me just copy the
above code
I'll paste it here and instead of India
I'll say
Japan
I'll run it there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from Japan
all right
now moving ahead now I want to know the
top 10 countries who have participated
since the Inception of Olympics in 1896.
so for that I'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
let's say equal to
I'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore TF
I'll say dot team
then I'll use the function
value underscore
counts
I'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just Mark the way in which I am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will throw you an error
I want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it I'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be short underscore
values and not value
let's run it again there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in Olympics since
1896 you have United States then we have
France so these are the number of
participants who have taken part since
1896
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada Japan
Sweden
we also have Australia and Hungary
I'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph so I am trying to
create a bar plot to plot the top 10
countries who have participated in
Olympics so here I'm using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now I'll tell you about this PLT X ticks
means just wait for a while
I have given a title to my plot saying
overall participation by country
and then
using the C bone library and the bar
plot function I am plotting the X and
the
y-axis so my x axis has top
I should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y-axis I'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then I'm using
a color palette called set 2.
let's run it
there you go so if I scroll down you can
see here we have a nice bar plot this is
a vertical bar plot and here you can see
the bars which represent the different
country names first we have United
States which has the highest
participation since the beginning of the
Olympics then we have France Great
Britain Italy Germany Canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes so for this we are going to
create a histogram
I'll be using the matplotlab library
specifically for this visualization
so I'll say PLT dot figure
will give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6.
I'll say
PLT
Dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want I'll see
each
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the X labels I'll
say PLT Dot
X label
this will have each
then we'll see PLT Dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next I'm going to use the hist function
so I'll say plt.hist
and I'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes underscore DF
Dot
each
which is my column name
comma
I am going to pass in the
bins
for that I am going to use the NP dot
e-range function so MP is for numpy
and inside this I'll say 10 comma
80 comma 2. so my bins will start from
the value 10 and go until 80 with a size
of 2.
comma
I'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins I
want my color to be orange
and then
I'll use
The Edge color to separate the bins
LC Edge color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color I want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be Edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the
age of the athletes you can see the
title is distribution of the athletes on
the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x axis we have the
age values ranging from 10 to 80 with a
size of
2
and if you say this we have most number
of athletes
who have each between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the Olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
Beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a few athletes even closer to 60
also and similarly we have a few
athletes who are under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so are all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
Olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter Olympic Games
just to give you a heads up the Winter
Olympic Games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here I have my variable name winter
underscore Sports so I'm extracting
for season equal to equal to Winter and
I am going to display only the unique
values now let me run this cell
okay so we can see here these are the
different winter sports that are
held during the winter Olympics now
similarly let's see for
Summer Olympics so what I'm going to do
here is I'll just copy this cell of code
and we'll edit the
variables I'll say summer
underscore Sports
athletes underscore DF Remains the Same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot uniquely means the same
and here I'll say summer underscore
Sports
this should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
mode number of Olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
Winter Olympics
so these are the sports that have played
on snow and ice and these are the sports
that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 Rio Olympics
all right
so I'll see
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
I'll use my
data frame that is athletes underscore
DF Dot
my variable name that is sex Dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the Inception of Olympics
we have more number of male participants
than female participants
now here in this current cell you can
see we are trying to plot a pie chart
for male and female athletes so I have
given my figure size then I have my
title as gender distribution I am using
the matplotlab library and the Pi
function I am using the variable gender
counts that we used here
then I am giving my labels as gender
underscore counts.index now I am using
this Auto PCT the auto PCT parameter
enables you to display the percent value
using python string formatting so this
is my string formatting that I have used
and I'm
initialize my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and I am also
giving Shadow to my pie chart so I have
written Shadow equal to True let's run
it all right so you can see here this is
my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female participation
so for me it is 72.5 percent for female
so far it is
27.5 percent as per the data set that we
have
you can change this start angle to let's
say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we are going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so I'll use my
data frame athletes underscore DF Dot
and then my column that is Middle I'll
say dot value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are very much similar
to each other the numbers are pretty
much the same
all right now it's time to focus on the
total female athletes who have taken
part in each
Olympics
so I'll create a variable called female
underscore
participants
I'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
DF
using square brackets
I'll see
athletes
underscore DF Dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
I'll use ampersand
I'll say
just copy this
paste it here
I'll say dot season
equal to equal to we'll check for Summer
Olympics
and I want to extract only
the gender column so here it is X comma
my year column which is year
okay
and then
I'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
I'll just copy this
paste it here
and then I'll use the group by function
say Group by which is part of the pandas
Library
I'll see here
and then I want to find the count
I'll reset the index
say reset underscore index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is I am
trying to filter my data only for the
female athletes for Summer Olympics and
here I am printing
the participation based on each year so
I'm finding out the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result there you go
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the Olympics
you can see it here for the Beijing
Olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
London Olympics we had
5815 Olympics similarly for the 2016 Rio
Olympics we had
more participation than the London
Olympics so 6223
women athletes that participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your data for female athletes so
I'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is Summer Olympics let me just run it I
have stored it in a variable called
women Olympics
now
here I am trying to find a
count plot or I am trying to create a
count plot using my c-bond SNS Library
I have set my style to dark grid then my
figure size I have given as 20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x-axis
as year
the data is women Olympics and Palette
I'm using as spectral and then I have
given a title women participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if I scroll down you can
see on the top I have the title for my
count plot which says women
participation and on the y-axis I have
the count and at the bottom you can see
the different year values from 1900 till
2000 and
16
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output so
this line graph shows the trend which
says plot for female athletes over time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually the women participation has
increased in Olympics since
its Inception there was a slight
decrease here this is around
1950s and again you can see here there's
a decrease with the women participation
in 1980 but since then since 1980 there
has been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section of
our analysis
we are going to filter the data to see
the details of the athletes who have won
gold medals
so I'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to I'll use my
data frame as athletes underscore DF
and
within parenthesis I'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
DF Dot
I'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
I'm going to say
gold medals dot head
let's run it there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won a gold medal you can see all the
records have middle as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis so here
I want to take only the values that are
different from any n so I'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that I have set gold
medals each
let me just run it cool
now I want to see
the athletes who have secured a gold
medal beyond the age of 60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of age
having won a gold medal
so here I'm going to say
gold medals
I'll use my
column as ID
and then
I'll use
my variable gold medals
and then
I'll say each
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
I'll run it and we'll see the result so
there are total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so I'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
I'll use the
same variable name gold medals
I'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
I'll give my
condition each
greater than 60.
now let's go ahead and we'll print
the variable sporting event
if I run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called Rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so I'll say PLT Dot
figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
I'll say PLT Dot
we'll use the
tight layout
sit tight underscore layout
then I'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore event
then I'll say PLT Dot
title
I'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if I scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot I have my title
gold medals for at least over 60 years
and since for archery we had three
players who secured a gold medal having
an each more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one Rook is one and shooting
we had One Medal
all right
now we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
I'll say
gold
medals
Dot we'll use the
region column
and
followed by that I'll use the
value underscore counts function and
I'll reset the index
with name
equal to I'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
USA
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have Russia Germany UK
and then we have Italy
cool
now in this cell I am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that I got above
so I've used my labels my titles I'm
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond Library I have my
x-axis my y-axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay and we'll run it
if I scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that I had used which is a rocket
and you can see USA has got the
most number of gold medals and we have
Russia Germany UK Italy and France now
we also have included France here which
was not present in this table the reason
being I have used head as six so it will
give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
Olympic event that is present in our
data set I'm talking about the 2016 Rio
Summer Olympics
so first of all I'll create a variable
called Max ear
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore DF
my column name here and I'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my Max here
I'll just show you the output you can
see here my Macs here present in the
data set is 2016 the Rio Olympics
next
we will create another variable called
team underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore DF
within square brackets I'll give
parenthesis and then see
athletes underscore TF
Dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my output that is Max here
which is actually 2016.
and then I'll say
ampersand
I'll just copy this
will paste it here
this time I'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
I'll say dot team
then I'll say team underscore names Dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go so in Geo Olympics
United States secured the
most number of gold medals now the
reason this is 137 is we have also
counted the team events for example
basketball
similarly Great Britain had 64 gold
medals in total
Russia 50 we have Brazil 34 Argentina 21
France 20 and Japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot I'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also I'll make the
corrections as team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it and you can see here we
have a nice
horizontal bar plot so we have United
States at the top Great Britain Russia
Germany China Brazil so here I am
displaying the top 20 Nations since I
have used head as 20
so these are the top 20 Nations who
secured the most number of gold medals
in the Rio Olympics
all right
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal now if you
had noticed here are
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
so for that I'll create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to I'll say
athletes underscore DF
then
I'll give my
let's make it DF
I'll give my condition
let me just copy this
I'll paste it here
and then
I'll give my condition height
and use the
not null
function
and then I'll say
ampersant
create another parenthesis I'll see
athletes underscore DF
this time we'll consider the weight
column
again I'll use the function as not null
and
I'll close the parenthesis
okay I had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now all right
we are going to create our final plot
I'll say PLT dot figure
I'll give my
figure size
equal to
I'll say 12 comma 10.
I'll say
access
equal to
SNS Dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
I'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis I'll have
height
comma
in my Y axis I'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore metals
comma
I'll use Hue equal to my sex column
cool
finally I'll say PLT dot I'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
Olympic
medalist
cool
now let's see our scatter plot this
might take some time to
give the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
Hue which is for male and female there
you go
so if I scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot on the top
we have the title of the plot saying
height versus wheat of Olympic medalist
you can see
are each as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on Olympics data set
analysis
so we used two data sets to
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we created some visualizations to
analyze and visualize the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on Olympics data set
analysis
Indian Premier League that is IPL is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
IPL 2022 will begin on 26th of March so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held IPL auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
Kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using Python and
jupyter notebook to answer specific
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see I have
some of the cells already filled in so
this will save us some time and we can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that I'll be using or the
IPython notebook cool so first let's go
ahead and import all the crucial
libraries that will be needed for our
analysis so here you can see I am
importing the pandas Library the numpy
library these are for data manipulation
and numerical competition then we have c
bond and matplotlib for data
visualization then
I have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we'll import
all the libraries okay it's done now the
next step is I'm going to create a data
frame in the name of IPL
and here I am importing the data set
using the read underscore CSV function
which is part of the pandash library so
PD here has been imported as pandas I am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is IPL
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
CSV is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have successfully
imported or loaded our data set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so I'll use the head function
for this
IPL dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the player was sold
or whether the player was a draft pick
so here Rashid Khan from Afghanistan
hardik pandya then we have subman Gill
these are all draft pick and then we
have the
price at which the players were listed
in the IPL auction then we have the type
of player whether the player is a bowler
an all-rounder A batsman or
a wicket keeper then we have the cost in
rupees this is in crores so basically
this column tells us the price at which
the player was sold in the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars after that we have
2021 Squad basically this means
in last year's IPL where was the player
so here you can see Rashid Khan was
playing
for SRH this one Rises Hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for Gujarat Titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for Mumbai Indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for which
are Titans
so on and so forth now let's see the
total number of players that are present
in the data set and the total columns
that are there for this I am going to
use
the shape attribute so I'll write IPL
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also and there are
total
eight columns in my data frame IPL
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so I'll say IPL dot
info which is a function so I have to
use brackets
there you go so here you can see it says
total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total eight columns
and then these are the different column
names and here you can see the total
non-null objects present in the
column and here you can see the data
types and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the data set
so if I say IPL dot columns and run it
it will give me all the different column
names that are present in the data frame
now as I said
the First Column which is unnamed colon
0 is actually unnecessary so we are
going to drop it for that
we are going to use the dot drop
function and then I have passed in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there and then I say
increase equal to True which means it
will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the unnamed column which
was the first column in the data frame
and now we have successfully removed it
so player becomes the first column in
the data frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so I'll say IPL dot I'm
going to use the is null function
followed by this sum function
if I run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost in rupees and
cost in dollars have nearly 396.
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
IPL auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the IPL
Squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the rows that have
cost in dollar as null or Nan so here I
have
used IPL and after that I am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then I've used the install function
if I run this
you can notice the cost in
dollars column all these values are n a
n or null
and even the same
rules have
any n for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the next task is to
fill these null values or any n values
with
zeros so for that I am going to use the
fill any function and here I have passed
in 0 so all the null values in the data
set will be replaced with 0 for
cost in rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it all right
okay
now
you will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means we will
check the rows that have null values for
the 2021 Squad column
so what I'll do is I'll say
IPL
Within
square brackets I'll say IPL and then
I'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 Squad
and then after this I'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if I run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 Squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is we will
replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 square column width
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
I'll say IPL
I'll pass in my column name which is
2021 Squad
equal to
I'll say IPL
2021
Squad
Dot
fill any
which is the function and here I'll pass
in a text or a string saying not
participated
all right let's run it before that let
me just scroll it down
now I'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
I'll just say IPL Dot
is null
and then I'm going to use this sum
function
if I run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the columns in the
IPL data frame have null value so it
shows 0.
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold but before that
we are going to
slice
a data frame so here I am looking for
all the rows where cost in rupees is
greater than
0
and those should be unique and
I am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the cost in
rupees is greater than zero
now
I'm going to create
another
column called status so I have written
IPL within square brackets I am passing
in the column name which is status and
that will be equal to the team
replaced by
sold value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if I just say IPL
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names I am using the
duplicated function and I'll say keep
equal to false which means I don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalit yadav we have
two entries so lalit yadav here is an
all-rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 IPL and
last year
he was playing for the Delhi capitals
and this year also
he is sold
to Delhi capitals
next we have
lalit yadav who happens to be a bowler
so this is again different lalitative
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have Amit Mishra
used to play with the Delhi capitals but
this time he remains unsold soon on so
forth so you can see two entries for
subham shring as well and Shivam Mishra
all right
now let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 IPL auction for that we have
already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again I am going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets I am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from Kegel
up next we are going to find how many
types of players have participated
so I'm going to say
types equal to
say IPL
I'll use the column name which is type
and I'm going to find the count of each
type of players that are present in the
data frame
I'm going to use the values underscore
counts function and then I'll say type
Dot
reset underscore index
if I run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it you can see here we have
the different types of players so all
rounders there are total 242 all
roundups were part of the auction then
we have 215 Bowlers 112 batsmans and 64
Wicket keepers
Now using the above table that we just
created
I am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that I'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi I'm
using
types dot values since I want only the
values from this table
and then
I'm saying labels equal to types dot
index
I have used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space and then this is my
format in which I want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution I am going to use Shadow so
it says Shadow equal to True which is
another parameter or an argument and
then I'm going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here I have used a title called Rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally I am saying PLT Dot Plot so let
me just run it there you go so here we
have a nice pie chart or a pi plot so
you can see the different pies here we
have all around the Wicket keeper batter
and bowler so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by Bowlers then we have 17.69
percent battles and 10.11 percent Wicket
Keepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this I am going to use a count
plot so we'll create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors one will have orange the other
one will have pink and I'm using labels
so to label the x axis and y axis I have
sold or unsold by label will have number
of players the title of my bar graph
would be sold versus unsold I am given a
font size of 15 and I'm saying
plt.plot now the function that you see
here at the bottom will display the data
labels for each of the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so I have used a figure size of 10 comma
5.
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
I'll say IPL
dot we can use the group by function
and I want to group it by status column
and
the value that I want to measure is
the players
count
so I'll say players
rather player and then I'm going to use
the count function if I run this you can
see here
I've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players around solder
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition I'm passing is in
the teams column the value shouldn't be
unsold
so players bot means the value should be
sold so here I'm using this condition
and the rest of the things Remains the
Same
one Improvement I have done here is I am
using X ticks rotation equal to 70
degrees this basically means the X
labels would be tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see I have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just show you so Gujarat Titans have
totally purchased 22 players
then
Delhi capitals have total 24 players in
their squad
again
Lucknow super Giants have 22 players
if I scroll and see again Bangalore
Royal Challengers or RCB they're all
challenges Bangalore have
22 players in the team
and Rajasthan Royals and Sunrisers
Hyderabad have 24 and 23 players
respectively in the teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns called
retention base price and base price unit
for that
first of all I am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to IPL
base price let me just run it
and then
I'm going to replace these values that
are present in the list to crore 40 lakh
20 lakh one crore 30 lakh 1.5 crore with
from auction and I'm saying in place
equal to True let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price so here
in the base price
column I'm going to replace draft pick
value as 0 so let's run that as well and
now
I'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
brace price unit and base price so
basically I am splitting
on the space that I have let me show you
how it is going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what I did was I replaced the draft pick
values to 0 and then the rest of the
values will be split into two columns
called base price unit so basically it
will have the unit of the base price
let's say crores or lakhs and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40 20 20
so on and so forth let me just scroll
down
and
run that particular cell
Now to create these two columns the base
price unit column and the base
underscore price column I have used the
Lambda function and I'm splitting based
on this piece
let's just run it
now I have replaced
retained with zero and let me show you
the
final data frame that I have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to 0
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that I wanted to
create so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick
any other value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores lags and the value
base price is 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skill up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so I'll say
IPL let me just scroll down DOT
I'm going to use the
Group by function
then I'll say
team
comma
retention
then I am going to
use the value as
retention because I want to find the
count of
retained players
and then I'll say colon minus 1.
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because I have
grouped by team and then retention so I
have changed Super Kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players coming to Delhi capitals
Delhi capitals in the 2022
IPL auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
I scroll down let me talk about let's
say Punjab Kings they have picked 23
players from the auction and retained
two players from
the team last year
talking about
RCB or oil challenges Bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here I am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold and I'm going to use another
parameter called Hue for the different
colors so here I have used Hue as type
because I want to show the players in
each team based on the different types
again I have given my
title to the bar plot
and then I have the X label the Y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if I scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for blue
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like Maroon is for
Wicked keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here I have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team so to solve
this question I'll see
my data frame name that is IPL
then I'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because you
want to see the highest amount spent and
not from the retained players
then I'm going to
group
by
I'll see
team
and then
I'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees that is in crores
and
I'll say
Max
coolant
minus 1
Dot
sort underscore
values
I'll say ascending equal to false which
means I want the sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
Mumbai Indians have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be Sean kison
then Chennai Super Kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is Deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores Kolkata Knight Riders
bought shreyas Ayer for 12.25 crores and
so on and so forth so these are the
highest amounts spent on a single player
by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at maximum value or maximum
price
now if you follow IPL the maximum
price up at which a player was retained
happens to be ravindra jadija so let's
see at what price was he retained
I'll say
retention
equal to equal to I'll say
retained
then I'll see
sort underscore
values
by equal to
I'll use the same column
cost in
rupees that's in crores
I'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot head
and I want to find the top layer
again there's some error let's see
where is the error
C is ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket I should say
bye
I think this should be
fine now let's run it there you go
so you can see here my result is player
name ravindra jadija who was written for
16 crores by Chennai Super Kings
cool
now the next cell of code will
display or print the top five Bowlers
who have been picked in this year's IPL
based on
their cost in INR
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here Deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shuttle thakur
who was bought by
Delhi capitals earlier he was part of
CSK
for 10.75 crores then we have proceed
the Krishna who has been bought by
Rajasthan Royals this time
last year he was with KKR and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly
lucky Ferguson has been bought by
Gujarat Titans and he played for KKR
last season he has been bought for 10
crores while his Peace Prize was too
crores then we have avish Khan
you can see avesh Khan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by Lucknow super Giants again
and lastly he was part of the Delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsmans pigged or batters
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if I run
this you can see here
was bought by
Kolkata Knight Riders for 12.25 crores
lasted it was part of Delhi capitals
then you have simran hitmeier who's from
West Indies he has been picked by the
Rajasthan Royals for 8.5 crores then we
have Rahul tripathi sikha Dhawan and
devdat particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's see all Rounders
you can replace batter with all rounder
if I run this you can see Lamb
Livingstone has been bought by Punjab
Kings this season for 11.5 crores his
base price was just one crore and last
year he was part of the Rajasthan Royals
then we have a player from Sri Lanka
asaranga then we have harshal Patel
Shahrukh Khan and Rahul devatiya who
have been the top five all-rounders
picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the IPL
last season but were not picked for this
year's IPL
so for that what I am doing is first I'm
renaming my 2021 Squad column this
column I want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
I am going to find out the unsold
players so here I am saying previous
team not equal to not participated and
then
I'm using another condition the team
should be equal to equal to unsold and
I'm going to find out only the player
and the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the IPL last
season but they haven't been picked this
season and last season they had played
for let's say Suresh Shrine update for
CSK Steve Smith was part of the Delhi
capitals succubal Hassan was part of KKR
if I scroll down you have David Milan
who played for Punjab Kings in 2021
or in Morgan
who played for KKR he also captained KKR
but unfortunately he was not picked this
season Chris Lane from Australia also
remained unsold this season
and to Tai we have been cutting Aditya
there are other players as well
we have Kane Richardson
cool so these were the players who are
part of the IPL season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on IPL data
analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualize the data and answered
some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 F1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform explority data analysis
and draw valuable insights so let's
begin by understanding what formula one
is
Formula 1 also known as F1 is a
motorsport defined by open wield single
sheet race cars it features the best
drivers in the most powerful and
technically Advanced cars
the sport is governed by the FIA that is
international automobile Federation here
10 teams comprising of two drivers each
compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a Constructor
champion
from that demonstration we'll be using
four data sets let me show them one by
one these are all CSV files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have
columns names in fact none of the data
sets have column names so while
importing the data set we'll assign the
column names using the names parameter
I'll show that in a while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result ID
then we have the race ID driver ID
we have the Constructor ID grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest lap then we also have
information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status ID
now moving on to the second data set
which is about races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so it has information about
the race ID the year in which the race
was held then we have
the round number circuit ID
then the name of the
Grand Prix so you can see here
Australian Malaysia and Chinese Spanish
Monaco Turkish British German
and others
then we have the date on which the GP
was held or the gone pre was held you
have the time and the URL which
basically leads to the Wikipedia page of
that particular
Grand Prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about drivers
now it has the driver ID the name of the
driver you can see here Hamilton rosberg
Alonso reichen
then we have Sato
Masa button Weber and all
after that we have the
number code
and we have the
full name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
and we have the Wikipedia page
for the driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
Constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
Constructor ID then the Constructor
reference
in Formula One
and this is the actual name of the
Constructor so we have McLaren
we have BMW server Williams then we have
Ferrari Toyota Red Bull force India
we also have Jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the URL
that is the Wikipedia page of that
particular Constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that I will
be using for this demo you can see some
of the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw under libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and Constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of F1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here I am importing numpy Panda
smartplotlib and c bond and after that
I'm writing percentage matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line I'll
hit shift enter to run it
will take some time there you go so if
you have successfully imported all the
libraries now the next step is to load
the data and assign
column names
so I'll load my
First Data which is results I'll say PD
Dot
read underscore
CSV
I'll give my
file name which is results dot CSV
and then using the
names parameter I'll pass in the
column names so actually I have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so I have this F1
notepad created which has the column
names I'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter I'll paste it
if I scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that have been
assigned
and that
I'm going to say
comma
and I'll write
header equal to none
I'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races I'll say
PD Dot
read underscore CSV
I'll give my
file name which is racist Dot
CSV
and then
I'll give the names parameter this is
actually names and not name
okay
I'm going to
copy the
second line
and I'll paste it here
and again
I'll say
header equal to none
we'll input our third data set which is
about
drivers
so I'll say PD dot read underscore CSV
I'll say
drivers dot CSV
then
again use the
names parameter
and I'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the drivers data set
here I
need to give
another parameter which is header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructor's data set
we'll see Constructors equal to PD dot
read underscore CSV which is the
function present in the pandas Library
I'll say
Constructors dot CSV which is my file
name
and then again I'll use the names
parameter
I'll go to my notepad and this time I'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
I'll paste it
and
here I'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says no such file or
directory drivers dot CSV
let's see
web host issue
okay they should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned The Columns to the
various data sets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here I'll create a data frame called
DF and I'll use
PD Dot merge function
first I'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above this file
and
I'm going to merge it with
racist data frame
and from the recess data frame I am
going to take
specific columns like the
race ID
then
I need the year
after that I need
name
next
I'm going to take
a round column as well
and
I'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and races so
here my common column is going to be the
race ID because it is present in both
the data sets
and I would like to merge
so for that I'm going to use how so I'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know SQL you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
I'll write DF equal to PD Dot March
I'll say DF comma and now I'm going to
merge the
reverse data set and
I'm going to select
specific columns so I'll say
driver ID
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then I'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma and then I want the
nationality of the driver
all right
we'll give a comma I'll say on
which column I want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver ID
again
how is going to be a left join
going to the final
merge part I'll say again DF equal to PD
Dot
merge
I'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which I have is about
Constructors
from Constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so I'll take the
Constructor
ID
then I'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here I'll say on equal to
the common column I'll use is
Constructor ID
and give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the food data sets
I'll hit
enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says Constructor
ID index
okay there is a spelling mistake this
should be
Constructor ID cool
let's run it there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns so I'll say DF
Dot
drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names I'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest lap
then we'll also drop the
status ID
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore ID column
and
going to drop the race underscore ID
column
will also drop
driver underscore ID column
and finally we are going to drop
the
Constructor underscore ID column
and I'll say access equal to
one
and in place I'll see equal to true
because I want to remove it from my
original data frame that is DF
there you go
now the next
thing I want to do is I want to rename
some of the columns so I'll say DF Dot
rename
I'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
I'm going to change the
rank
to
stressed
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now I'll say
name underscore X
equal to
I'll say the
Grand Prix name so I'll say GP
underscore name
scholar I'm going to focus is
the nationality column so I'll say
nationality underscore
X
I'll give a colon the value I'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that I am going to change it to
Constructor name
another comma
I want to see
nationality
underscore y
Olan
change it to
Constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column and that I am
going to replace with
just
driver
finally I'll see
in place
equal to
true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell I'm going to rearrange
the columns so here I am using the same
data frame and we have just renamed the
columns so starting with your grand
prename round driver
nationality and others
let's run this
up next
we are going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete so I'll say DF equal to
DF
then I'll see
yo
not equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the value so I'll say DF equal to
DF Dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name I'm going to sort it by
year
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma I'll say
ascending equal to
first let's say is false
next I have true
and then I'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash n values in the time column
with something called Nan because the
time column was not registered when a
driver did not finish a race or was
slapped by another driver
so to do this I am going to say DF Dot
time
dot I'm going to use the replace
function
and here I'll say
forward slash or backward slash
n
and I'm going to replace with
numpy's Nan
I'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
meters
I'm going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds Dot
replace I'll paste it here
then I'll say DF Dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore rank Dot
replace
it
next I have
DF Dot
fastest Dot
lab
Dot
time
say replace
to that I have
the next column which is speed so I'll
say fastest
underscore lap underscore speed Dot
replace
I'll paste it
so here I'm going to replace
this particular value the
backward slash n with Nan
let me run it cool
step I'm going to change the data types
for fastest underscore lab underscore
speed to float then fastest underscore
lab underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float again for milliseconds also
we are changing it to float values
let me run it
now
I'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
I'll say DF Dot
reset
underscore
index
I'll say
drop
equal to
true
we'll give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial processing step of the
data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll check the head of
the data set now to see the total number
of
rows and columns I'll say print DF dot
shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use DF dot info function
so it gives me the
year the Grand Prix name
the round number
driver Constructor name grid position
order total number of points time
then time in milliseconds the first slap
rank the fastest lap speed the
nationality of the driver the
nationality of the Constructor then here
we have the total number of non-null
objects
then you also have the memory usage at
the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so I'll see DF
Dot head let's say I want to check the
first 10 rows
there you go
if I scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the Grand Prix
name round driver Constructor name and
other columns now let me just brief you
about what these column names stand for
so the year column that you see here is
this season that the Grand Prix took
place and then we have the name of the
Grand Prix now the round column is the
number of the arrays in each season for
example one means it was the first race
of the season and then two means it was
the second race of the season so so on
and so forth then we have the name of
the driver
for that we have the
name of the car Constructor so you can
see Ferrari Mercedes Red Bull Renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the burner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if I just scroll down
I'll just move to the right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lap
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during a race
next we have fastest lap time that is
the shortest amount of time that took to
complete a lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the Constructor
nationality that is the country where
the car Constructor is based out of
okay
now here I am going to set my figure
size to 10 comma 6 this is going to be
for all the plots that we are going to
create afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the Grand Prix windows
so here I'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
TF dot I'll say Loc
then I'll say DF
I want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver one there is
and then
I'm going to use the
Group by function
I'm going to group it by driver
and
values I'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore values
I'll say
ascending equal to
false
we change it to two underscore frame
Dot
reset underscore
index
what essentially I am doing here is I am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and won a Grand Prix
next
I'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so I'll say
SB
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be SNS but SB
also will work so I'll say SB Dot
bar plot
I'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
in the y-axis I'll have
driver
in the x-axis I'll have
position
underscore
order
then I have
color equal to
green
that I'll set my
Alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so I'll say PLT
Dot title
let's say most Grand Prix
winners in F1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label I will have
driver
name
we have the X label
that will have
number of
Grand Prix wins
and I'll see
PLT Dot
y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot shows
that there are a large distribution of
ground prevents only a few drivers in
history of F1 have won over 20 Grand
Prix in their careers and there are some
drivers who completely dominated the F1
racing and have won over 50 Grand Prix
in their career so we are going to focus
on those top 5 or top 10
drivers in the next section so what I'm
doing here is from the
above result that we just got I'm going
to filter out only the top 10 so I'm
going to use the head function
and
inside that I passed in 10 if I print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have Michael Schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 GP events then we
have Hamilton Vettel Frost Cena Alonso
then we have Stewart Clark and Laura uh
the data that we have is not the most
recent one so if you check the actual
stats Hamilton has actually overtaken
Michael Schumacher and has won over 100
three close to 103 races as of now
and next we have Michael Schumacher so
this is not the most recent data
cool
Now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so I'll say SB Dot
bar plot
I'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so I'll say top 10
drivers
in the y-axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis will have
position
underscore
order
for the bars I'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
I'll set my Alpha value
to be
0.8
and I'll say let's see
line
width
equal to
0.8
and I'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the same drill I'm going to give
a title to my plot so I'll say PLT dot
title
most
GP windows in a phone
you give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then I'll have
X label which will have
number of
on-prey wins
pool
let me see if everything is fine and
then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal bar plot that shows the
top drivers in a phone so as per our
data that we have we have Michael
Schumacher who has won over 91 or close
to
91
races then we have Hamilton battle
Alonso Clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top Constructors that
have participated in F1 so here I'm
finding out
all the
Constructor windows so here
I'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then I'm using
the group by
based on the Constructor name
and then I'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values in
descending order and I'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot I'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
Constructor underscore winner in the
y-axis I'll have the Constructor name on
the x axis I'll have the position order
so you can see here I've used color as
pink and I've given a title acceptable
by label
and white ticks let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of Constructor names
now our next task is to
check the
top 10 GPA Constructor windows so here
I'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if I run it you can see
here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races or Ferrari McLaren Williams then
we have Mercedes Red Bull Tim Lotus
Renault
I know those
okay now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10 Constructors
let me show you how to do it
so I'll see
SB which is for c bond Dot
bar plot
I'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 Constructors
scroll down I'll see Constructors
y-axis I'll have
Constructor
on the x-axis I'll have
position underscore order
then
I'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then I'll set my Alpha to
0.8
I'll see
line width equal to
0.8
and my
Edge color I'll say
black
that I'll say PLT Dot
title
see top 10 most
GP wins
LT Dot
by label would be
Constructor
name
and I'll have PLT Dot
X label
as
number of
GP events
cool
let's run it there you go so here you
can see we have Ferrari at the top then
we have McLaren Williams Mercedes I'm
pretty certain by the end of 2021 season
Mercedes could have gained a lot of wins
since Hamilton has been on the top
for Mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing position vary
so to do that I'm going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the pit Lane
so I'm using this function called reg
plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the starting and
finishing position so on the x axis we
have the starting position on the y axis
we have the
finishing of the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right now we can also see that most
recess had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years now since this
data is only available from 2004 onwards
so we have
we have taken years that start from 2004
onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed amongst all teams during
the fastest lap at individual Grand Prix
and here on the
y-axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different GPS and
you can see here the ear values now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around 2015
for almost all these circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speech
started
to increase
you can see here there's a increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that the speed is
very different on each track for
instance if you check the
Italian Grand Prix which is here
Italian GP has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you talk about the Monaco Grand
Prix let me show you if you see here the
Monaco GP is the slowest race with
average speed below 160 kilometer per
hour now this is actually expected
because the Monaco Grand Prix
has very narrow streets and hence the
drivers cannot drive fast in this
circuit data analysis using Python and
taking the top 1000 Instagram influencer
data set
before we start I hope this screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I'm repeating again I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
shoes do let us know in the chat section
so that we can resolve them
in today's session we will go through
the data analysis using python we
already have a data set with us where we
have data of top 1000 Instagram
influencer we will analyze this data set
using python before we move on to the
programming part let's discuss data
analysis and the steps and the
importance of the same
data analysis is a process for acquiring
arranging and changing data so that
prediction about the future and the data
driven decision can be made
finding potential answer to business
problem is also helpful let's move
forward and see steps to perform data
analysis
so first one is Define the question what
commercial issue are you attempting to
resolve by raising it as a query you can
concentrate on coming up with the
precise response
and the second one is collecting data to
answer specified research question test
hypothesis and evaluate outcomes data
collection is the act of acquiring and
measuring information on variables of
interest in a systematic and defined
manner and the third one is cleaning
data your data should be explored
cleaned up and deducted and organized as
a necessary to whatever needs to be done
but wait a moment give it some time
and the fourth one is analyzing data
perform a variety of analysis to gain
insights concentrate on a descriptive
diagnostic predictive and prescriptive
types of data analysis and the fifth one
is visualization and sharing your
findings
how can you most effectively impart your
knowledge and suggestions the trick is
using communication and visualization
Technologies together after seeing these
steps to perform data analysis let's
move forward and see some importance of
data analysis so python is a high level
open source interpreted language that
offers a fantastic approach to
object-oriented programming it is the
one of the greatest language for a
variety of projects and applications
according to data scientists working
with mathematical statical and
scientific function is a base with
python it provides top-notch libraries
for working with data science
application
python is the one of the most widely
used programming language in the field
of science and research due to its
Simplicity and use
this means that even those without
engineering skills might quickly learn
how to utilize it furthermore it works
better for rapid prototyping there are
some most common libraries used for data
analysis the first one is numpy
pandas
matplotlip sci-fi
C bone
and many more
so
so what do you guys think about data
analysis do share your thoughts with us
in the chat section
now let's move to our programming part
to perform data analysis using python so
first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open
new python file
so this is how the UI looks like so at
first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in mathematical functioning so the first
one is numpy numpy is a python Library
used for working with arrays it also has
a functions for working in the domain of
linear algebra and matrices it is an
open source projected and you can use it
freely numpy stand for numerical python
so we will write
import
come by
as NB
so here NP is denoting numpy
so we will import the next libraries
pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structures and operations for
manipulating numerical tables and time
series so we will write
import
and as
as PD
here PD is for denoting pandas so we
will
close back
so after importing the libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write data
equals to PD dot read underscore CSV
and here we have to write our data set
name
data set
insta dot CSV
press shift plus enter yeah here PD is
for pandas Library read is used for
reading the data set
from the machine and CSV is used for the
type of file which you want to read so
then we can write data to see our data
so
see this is how our data set look like
so let's first rename this column name
followers
this one followers in Million by writing
followers only because it is so lengthy
and this followers column we are going
to use most of time so it will save our
time
so we will write here data
dot rename
column
equals to that Curly braces
here we will write the name of column
which you want to rename all words
colon
to followers
so here we will write in place
equals to true
okay then here we will write data
okay it's not changed yet
okay okay because it is followers
to give one space here
yeah done so rename function is a
function which is used to rename the
column name so there are many keywords
arguments like index column access copy
in place level errors which you can use
as a parameter so column name is changed
to followers let's move on so here you
can see the three dots this one
and we are unable to see our full data
like only we can see the 10 rows so like
we have thousand rows right so for that
we can write
here we can write PD dot set
underscore options
display
dot Max
underscore columns
and here we can write
none
after that this is for columns and we
can write for the same for the rows
sort underscore options
it is option not options
okay we can write here display
dot Max
underscore for rows
perfectly done okay we can write here
none
yep so pandas features and options this
one
system that allows you to modify various
aspects of their behavior users are most
likely to change display related options
so the maximum number of rows by default
is done you can see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten so the
maximum number of rows by default is 10.
all rows of data frame are considered if
the value is set to none set the display
value by setting x max rows to none and
passing it to the set option all rows
from the data frame will be shown so
let's move on
and see our full data
by writing data frame name here
so
okay let me debug the error
okay here column name
l u
MNS okay sorry
so here we can write data
so see this is how our datas look like
the Thousand rows
full thousand rows like from 999 to zero
yeah
so moving ahead here you can see the NN
values like this n a n
and Below n a n n
so NN means not a number and it is one
of the typical methods for representing
the data set missing values it is a
unique floating point value and can only
be changed to the float type so let's
change it to 0 for the better results
and the better prediction so we will
write here data dot fill
any
zero
so by writing this we will shift plus
enter
so all na values are now changed to zero
with the help of this fill in a function
this fill in a method replaces the null
values with a specified value so after
this let's move on to the another
function which is shape
so we will write data dot shape
then shift plus enter yeah so this shape
function will return you a number of
rows and columns your data set have
so here we have thousand rows you can
see
and seven columns
yeah so let's move on to the another
amazing function which is info so here
we will write data dot info
effect so data frames information is
printed within four method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use range
index and another number of cells in
column note that the information method
does indeed print the information
so here you can see all information has
been printed like all the columns name
all the non-null values count and data
types for the particular column so let's
move forward and see our next function
which is data dot columns so which is
data dot columns
okay again I wrote wrong
minus
okay perfect so as per the name you can
easily tell me in the chat section what
is going to print for us
so
this function is going to print all the
columns name so here we have names like
name rank category followers audience
country authentic engagement engagement
average data type is object why data
type is object data type is object
because this is taking as the one
category that is why it is taking as an
object so let's move forward for the
next function which is described so data
frame comprises of numerical data and
each column's description includes it
following details like count is the
total amount of non empty values mean
the standard deviation and many others
so here we will write data Dot describe
Open brackets
so
C
so here you can see all the columns
which have numerical data is displayed
by the full description
so this is our mean
count STD minimum 25 percent of the
particular date column 50 and 70 percent
and the maximum value
present in the column so moving forward
let's solve some questions like how to
show audience country like from which
country we have the most number of
followers so let me write this question
as a comment so for comment we have to
use hashtag so here you can write how to
show
audience
from
pitch
country we have
most
number of followers
okay perfect yeah so let's solve this
with a small line of code we can write
here data
here column name as audience
entry
dot value
underscore
counts
normalize
was to true
then we will round it it to
two
okay here we have to write the capital T
perfect
yeah
so returns an object with counts of
distinct value the resulting object will
be arranged in descending order with the
first element being the one of the that
appears most frequently by default
exclude any values index value count
normalize equals to false sort equals to
True ascending equals to false or bins
equals to none is a syntax of counting
values the normalized function in Python
processing package is used to normalize
the data it accepts an area as input and
converts its content to a range between
0 and 1. after that it will give a back
an output array with the same size of
input array if we remove round function
it will show the output like it is still
showing the values but we round this
value for how many decimal places we
have to see the value that is why I has
written 2 here for two decimal places so
we will write
here
yeah the data look like good
so from this question we can say
maximum audience is from United States
with like 28 percent followed by India
like 16 percent and Brazil 15 and so on
so
let's move to the our next question
which is how to show audience country
like who is having more followers from
India or a particular country
so let me write it as a comment
so
how to
audience
okay this is three hashtag
so
audience
country
like who is
having
more
followers
the question is that like who which
influencer is having more followers from
India
so
don't worry we will like do for the more
and more countries so
here I have to write data underscore
IND for India so equals to data
and again data this is our data frame
name so
audience
see
here we can write double squares to
yeah
here we can write data
so here we are giving data IND name of
you can say a variable name and data is
our data frame name and audience country
is column name and India is a country
name from which we want to collect
influencer so let me do this
let me debug the error audience country
Okay C is capital here
yeah perfect
so
these all influencers are who has
audience from India so like Cristiano
Virat Kohli that khabi Justin Bieber
Instagrams in the rock
and so on
so so let's take another country this
time we will take United States
so we will write here data underscore
USA
okay data
data again
and
audience
C is capital now country
perfect
question equals to
it is USA or United States
in the United States perfect
so United
States
so data
dot USA
this time I'm using
uh
score and Dot head
so we have to write same code like we
did for India here I have used the head
function
you can see the head function
to show only five first rows
you can also write only data USA so to
see the full data so I will write like
this I can do like this so here I can
see the full data
The influencer Who belongs to United
States that audience country belongs to
United States so
I will control that or head function
yeah
so okay let's do for One More Country
browse it so let's write data
it uh uh underscore Brazil
data
again data
but audience
is capital country equals equals to
oh Brazil how this return
[Music]
okay Brazil P capital
so here we will write Brazil
e is capital forgot
so here we will add data underscore
Brazil
so we have to write same code like we
did for India and USA so here let me use
a function called tail
so
here I have used the tail function to
show only last five rows head will show
you the first five rows and the tail
will show you the last five rows so you
can also write only Brazil to see full
data so let's move forward and see our
next question which is
like how to show audience for a
particular category
so let me write this question as a
comment for your better understanding
and readability
so here we will write
how
to show
audience
for a particular
category
okay
so this time I will use fashion category
so let's write code for this one so
fashion
equals to data underscore USA
data underscore USA
right here category
okay dot Str
Dot
contains
to write your fashion
comma any
equals to false
okay fashion
bats
yeah here I am using the data USA set
for retrieving the fashion category we
can do this for all the data using our
data frame name we can also write data
only here so I have given the column
names as a category and Str contains
means string which contains fashion this
is what we have to print and any should
not be false
okay so let's see
if white is showing this uh data
underscore USA
okay here f is capital
it's capital
so
yeah okay
see these all influencers which have
audience from United States like Kendall
Jenner zandia and Beyonce
so these all influencers which have
audience from United States and belong
to some kind of fashion industry
so moving ahead let's take one more
category this time we will take a sports
category because Sports is something
like which most of people like so we
will write here Sports
this time we will take India data set
IND I guess we have wrote the same yeah
so here we will write data
underscore
ie
and
category
same Str dot contains
of
it
we will write here
we check one thing
so Sports as his capital
port
comma any
equals to
false
then Sports again
okay this time we will use Sports dot
hat
so use India data and all the things are
same just replace fashion with the
sports
so
see these are all the influencer
Cristiano Virat Kohli cabi Roy Sharma
hardik pandya which have audience from
India and belong to some kind of sports
industry so as I'm talking before like
we can use data frame name for all data
instead of using like India data or
like this one so we can also write like
this data only
okay let me
create one more
for the
or only data so we can write like here
Sports
so
data
here we can
here we are like taking our data like
full data frame name so we can write
category
category name
so
dot Str dot contains
contains
ports
comma n a equals to
false
okay here we will write export
okay
so as I'm talking before like we can use
data frame name so instead of like
writing only data and your data USA
browsy so this influencers like from
Sports category belong to any one
country so this is our full
influencer category so let's move
forward and
do this again for the music category
like because music is also one of the
favorite category of you folks
so we have to write music
okay music
was you
we will do is for the whole data so data
data
category
PR Dot
contains
I guess m is capital in music
yep
it's Capital so music
my n equals to
so this data will contain all the
category influencer name which belongs
to music category whether they are from
India USA Brazil or any other country
doesn't matter
see you can see Indonesia South Korean
so moving forward let's change our some
column data types to integer type
so we can write here data
equals to
data dot as type
count bracket then curly braces so here
we can write
followers
if followers followers
foreign
and take it from here authentic
engagement
overcome the spelling mistakes so I can
check from here
integer
uh
that's two four one more engagement
average
go integers
so here we can write data dot hat
yeah perfect
all the columns changed to in scissor
type now so this is how we can change
like data type and column here like data
is our data frame name
this one and the as type this one as
type
is the method like which gives a back a
new data frame with the requested data
type
for the data to select a data type for
each column you can either cast the
entire data frame so that the type or I
use Python dictionary like in the
following example like categories pearls
or whatever respectively
I repeat calories per decision are all
in like integers value respectively so
let's move to our next question which is
like top 20 character grief by follower
before making graph for this one let me
create like top variable followers
so
here I can write like 20 top
20
all words
2.
data
Dot and largest
and largest
like we need 20 so we can write here
I am writing followers spelling like
this because we have to look like this
followers f o l l w e r s so
of it
yeah so top 20 followers we have taken
as a variable name to store followers
and to obtain the first and rows
arranged by the column in descending
order use of the and largest function
which is this one and largest function
in specified columns are also written uh
I repeat but they are not used to
determining ranking so data frame dot
enlarges you can write the syntax like
this self comma like n comma column
names or keep you can also write keep
equals to first so top 20 followers are
generated let me create graph so
first we will import Library like one of
the main library for visualization which
is matplotlib so for importing this we
have to write import
gave so
we can also write
like
instead of writing import we can also
write from
matplotlib
import
port
by a plot
as
LT
so for the Python programming language
and it's some bi numerical mathematics
matplotlib is a graphing library with
the help of general purposes like GUI
toolkits like Tinker python QT and gtk
it offers an object-oriented API for
embedding plots into applications
so after this let's create
the figure so we have to write PLT Dot
eager
that you can figure size
equals to
we can take 12 and 8
perfect
so we will get figure 2 here
equals to PLT dot bar
top 20
but we have to take followers
dot category
comma category
top
20
followers
okay followers
but
followers
comma like label should be
should be followers
it should be
like I'm taking 0.8 here
uh my favorite color is maroon
so I will take
maroon color
so
PLT
dot X sticks
font size
should be like 12 and rotation
should be 90
perfect
so let's create Y and X labels so PLT
dot y label
followers
followers
from our font size
should be let me take 16 here
and plt.x label
category
and font size should be font size
should be 16.
so let's set the title for this now for
plt.ti
title
is
oh
20
categories
the words
comma
font size
should be let's
take it as 20
and PLT Dot
underscore layout
layout
listen and we can write PLT Dot
tick
label
underscore format
is equals to
y
why
style should be plain
okay
so this is how the visualization look
like here I have used the bar graph for
this visualization and top 20 followers
dot category and this one top 20
followers dot followers are the X and Y
values and color is something like which
color you want to show with and you can
choose as your preference and X and Y
labels are used to print in X and Y
coordinate like this followers in
millions and category so this tight
layout this one this type layout
and
I repeat
this tight layout function this one
and this type layout function this one
this title out function in pipelot
module of matte plotly libraries used to
automatically adjust subplot parameters
to give a specified padding so plt.tick
label format is used for in which Axis
or in which style you want to print
plt.tick label is not necessary to write
or to showing paragraph So
like when we can remove this so our
visualization should look like this so
it is not necessary
okay
tools that
so let's move to our next question like
using bar graphs
let's see how our category look likes so
first we will create
I'm writing here
showing
categories
using
pie chart
okay
so using
using pie chart let's see how our
category look likes first we will create
categories so we have to write here
like types
equals to data Dot
category
Dot
value
underscore counts
and this one yeah types
okay
types
dot reset
underscore index
yeah here we have used types as a
variable and value counts uh like we
already discussed before
so these all are the categories
from our data
so let's create the pie chart now so for
plotting a pie chart we have to write
PLT dot pi
like types dot values
values comma label
should be
types dot Index this one label should be
type dot Index this music Cinema
lifestyle modeling and so on so index
comma
label distance
to 1.2
and then Auto
PCD should be
like
some days 1.2
f
percentage so like
shadow
should be true
perfect and let me add one more thing
start
angle
should be 60.
okay so PLT Dot
title
that is like
you can say different
categories
comma font size
should be 20
and that's PLT Dot
plot
so let me check everything is correct
values labels okay here we can write
labels
type dot values labels equals to type
dot index and label distance equals to
1.2
so here Auto PCT is equals to
like
okay Shadow equals to True perfect and
starting is equals 20 60 so PLT dot
title different categories okay okay
fine everything is great
so
it's not coming okay perfect so this is
how our pie chart look like this is
looking like a mess because we have more
than 100 categories that is why like 100
percent is splitting into 152 categories
like you can see here
we have 152 categories
Okay so
this is how
sorry this is how our like pie charts
look like for our different categories
let me write D capital
yeah perfect creating a telegram board
using python but before we begin if you
love watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to now
miss an update
in this session we will create a simply
learn board that will help it suitors to
choose from various courses offered by
simpler
now let's understand the uses of boards
the first use of board is to get
customized notifications and news a
board can act as a
smart newspaper sending relevant content
with subscribers as soon as it's
published
the next use is accept payments a board
can offer paid services or work as a
virtual storefront another users create
custom tools a board May provide you
with alerts weather forecasts
translations formatting or other
services and another uses build social
services a board could connect people
looking for conversation Partners based
on common interests or proximity
with the understanding of uses of boats
now let's create our own mode
you will have to follow the steps to
create a telegram board
and the first requirement to create a
port is you should have a telegram
account
now let's move to Telegram
and using the telegram we will interact
with the telegram Port further which is
going to provide us with the board and
the token which will act as a password
for that port and then we will create a
Python program to do all these
interactions
so you need to get the telegram map
whether on the desktop or in your mobile
phone I am going to use desktop versions
you can download the desktop app from
desktop block telegram.org
I will show you how to download it
desktop dot Telegram
.org
here you can see that Windows bit 64
version is available and you can see all
the platforms and you can choose
according to your needs
I have installed the windows 64-bit
version
and
the telegram app
I will search for the board file
and be careful and click on the verified
one with the blue tick this is the one
just click on it and you can click on
the start to start the conversation with
the Board Puzzle you can see the various
commands
here
and board father is again a board which
telegram has created in order to do
automation of all the board creations
and now to create a new board we'll
start with the command Slash new board
here you can see this is the command you
can click on that or just right here
slash
new board
now the fatherboard has replied all
right a new board how are we going to
call it please choose a name for your
Bot
so here you have to choose a name for
your board
I will go with the name upscale by
simply learn for my board
now the father vote has replied good now
let's choose a username for your board
it must end in board like this for
example Tetris port or Tetris underscore
board you need to make sure that the
username is unique and it ends with
underscore port or it should have bought
at the end of the username
what further to inform you if your
username is already taken so I would be
going with the username
scale underscore 1122
quotes simply done
and export
and the board father replied then
congratulations on your new board you
will find it at this is the link hey if
you click it you will just get to your
board
and we have received the token for our
board
here you can see use this token to
access the HTTP API this is your token
and the board for the set keep your
token secure and store it safely it can
be used by anyone to control your board
as soon as you receive the token you
have to write another command that is
slash set privacy
and press enter
it will change the privacy settings for
your Port so no one can misuse your
board token and now you have to choose
the port you want to change the privacy
settings
so we are currently working on the
upscale underscore 1.22 underscore
simply an underscore board so we'll
choose this and here you can see that
the security is enabled you have to
write disable or choose disable from
here
now success the new status is disabled
so your Port is now secure and your
token can misused by anyone else
this is how we created a board and now
we will use this in Python program first
we will see the external packages we
need to install for this project
for that
we will move to command prompt
and install the packages
the first package is PIP
install
python
hyphen telegram hyphen board
as you can see the package is already
installed on my system so you have to
install the package and then open your
idea
for that I will create a folder
and I will name it as telegram board
and inside I will open my ID ID for that
I'll write the command CMD
and open my visual studio code
now I will create a new file and name it
as
telegram Dot py
foreign
first thing I'll do is import
telegram.exe
now we are going to load the token
provided by the board for the so we'll
move to
Telegram
and copy the token provided by the board
father so this is our token
we will copy it and move back to our
ideally
and create a new variable
that would be token
a token
in it
now we'll create the updater object this
object will be used to perform actions
with our border so we're going to write
the command
of data
equal to Telegram
dot EXT
Dot
up data and we'll pass the token and use
context equal to true in it
first we will copy our
token and pass another variable that is
use underscore context
and that would be equal to true
and now we're going to get the
dispatcher we will create a variable
with the name
dispatcher
and that would hold up data
load dispatcher
now we'll add the functions to give our
board some functionalities
we will start with the start command if
the First Command usually given to the
board
for that we will write
Define that would be defining the
function with the name start
and inside we will pass update
and context
as we have used the use underscore
context as true we will use the context
for some information
and when someone starts the conversation
with about what should be a first
message
they will set the first message as
welcome to Simply learn for that you
will write
update Dot message
Dot
reply underscore text
and inside will store a message
that would be hello
welcome to Simply learn
next we will Define another function
that is help
and for that we'll write the command in
the app
help
and we'll pass the same update and
context
and inside this function we will send
the message with the commands that would
be start help content and the python
playlist or SQL playlist told Java
playlist that the user wants to persuade
or which course he want to persuade
so we will start with
date Dot
message dot reply
underscore text
and inside
we will Define all the commands
so we'll go with the triple columns
so our first one would be start and it
would symbolize
welcome to the channel
and our next one would be help only
and it would indicate
this particular message
the next command will Define as content
and this would be about various
playlists of Simply run
foreign
playlist
and if the user write this command to
avoid he will just direct it to the
first video from the python playlist
and next command we would write about
SQL
and it would also direct it to the first
video
from SQL playlist
and the next up command would be about
Java
and it would also direct to the first
video from the ciao playlist
foreign
that would be contact
and that would hold the contact
information if someone wants to contact
to Simply learn from further information
and now
we will Define all these commands
for that
will
write the function
final content and will pass
update and
context
and inside
will just uh output
to the users
with the command update Dot message
dot reply underscore text and the output
that good users will see is we have
various playlists and articles available
and now similarly we will
update the next function we will copy
this
foreign
copy the function
and next function would be python
so if the user
type python in the chat board
so he will just drag it to the first
video from python playlist
for that
we'll copy the link of the
first video from the playlist python
paste in the message dot reply
underscore text
and for that we'll write
tutorial link
and paste the link of the video
and now we'll do the same
for SQL and Java
we will copy the function
and change the name to the SQL
and copy the link
of the first video of SQL from the
playlist
and now we will do the same for the Java
for that we'll copy the function
and paste here and name it as server
now we'll move to the job playlist
and copy the link of the first video
from the playlist
and paste it here
now we are done with the functions
python SQL Java and we are left with
contact so we will declare another
function
for that also we will copy the same
function
and name it as contact
and inside
you can contact
and I registered mail ID
provide it on the website
so these are some functions which we can
add to that is better we will create a
command Handler to handle the certain
command and map the function to it and
then add the command Handler to the
dispatcher
so first we will write the command
that is
this Patcher
dot add underscore handle
and inside
we will write Telegram
dot EXT dot command Handler
and inside you will pass
the name of the command that will be
inputted by the user and the function
name
for deck
all right
first you'll write the command
that is
start
and the function defined bias for the
command start
is also with the name start
now we'll copy this command and
do the needful for all the functions
so here we
change the command
that would be python
and the function name
and the same for SQL
and same to Java
foreign
that is contact
and in the end
fill right command
updated dot start underscore o link
so it will check if our code is working
or not
and updater Dot idle
it is used when the user just enters the
First Command so it will not exit the
program it will wait for user to enter
other commands
always for good to write a command for
help
for that we'll copy the command
right help will save the program
and
click on the Run button
here we can see that the program is
running fine
now we'll move to the telegram
and
click on a port username you can also
search the PO or what username here it's
globally searchable
now we'll click on the start
on the start command we have got the
output hello welcome to Simply learn
now we will put slash help
and here we have got all the commands
that is let's start slash help and this
particular message will appear when we
click on the slash help or just write it
here
when you click on slash python you will
get the first video from the python
playlist and when we click on the slash
SQL
we will get the first video from the SQL
playlist
and similar with the Java we'll get the
first video from the job playlist
and when we
click on the command slash contact we
get the output you can contact on the
registered mail ID provided on the
website
so we have done with our telegram board
we have created this telegram board
successfully hello everyone I am mayank
and welcome to Simply learn today we
will take you through the hands of lab
demo of how you can create phase
detection using opencv python before we
start I hope the screen is clearly
visible and the audio is fine if yes
please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
I am repeating again before we start I
hope this screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
if I forgot to reply someone's comment
sorry for that
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join until then let me tell
you guys that we have regular updates on
multiple Technologies if you are a tech
geek on a continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
it I think we can get started so in
today's session we will see what opencv
is moving forward we will see what is
space detection and at the end we will
go through the hands of live demo of how
we can create phase detection using
opencv python we will perform different
function and use different python
libraries to create phase detection
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what opencv is and
proceed further for the same
what is opencv
a collection of python bindings called
opencv python was created to address
issue with the computer vision
pythony's general purpose programming
language created by Judo Von Rasam that
quickly gained popularity largely due to
its ease of use and readable code the
programmer can express Concept in less
code without sacrificing readability
numpy a highly efficient library for
numerical operation with a Matlab like
syntax is used by opencv python
numpy arrays are translated into and out
of all opencv array forms additionally
this make it simpler to interact with
other numpy using libraries like scipy
and matplotlib after understanding what
is opencv let's move forward and see
what phase detection is so what is Phase
detection
phase detection also known as facial
detection is a computer technology that
uses artificial intelligence to find and
recognize human faces in digital
photographs
Fair detection technology can be enabled
real-time surveillance and tracking of
people in various Industries such as
security Biometrics law enforcement
entertainment and personal safety
from basic computer vision method to
developments in machine learning to
increasingly use complex artificial
neural network and related Technologies
phase detection has advanced leading or
to ongoing performance increases
it now serves as the foundation from
some crucial applications such as face
tracking phase analysis face recognition
the application ability to perform
sequential tasks substantially impacts
the phase detection
so dear learner if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or give your answer
in the chat section so I can see if the
answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
factorial
print
seed
sqrt
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section please do
let me know your answers
so I am starting the timer of one minute
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python factorial
print seed sqrt let us know your answer
in the comment section below
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this session
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
30 seconds more factorial print seed
sqrt
please let me know your answer in the
comment section below
20 seconds remaining
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
10 seconds more
please let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the current response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to create phase detection using
opencv python
so first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a phase
detection system
so first let me rename this
paste
Direction
first we will import import
CV2
press enter then import another Library
import numpy
as NP
and the third one is Major One Import
face
recognition
as
fr
then press enter
so CV means capturing video so the CV2
function is an opencv can read video
video capture by using pass 0 function
parameter we can access our webcam we
may pass as rtsp URL in the function
parameter to capture the CCTV footage
which is quite helpful for video
analysis
and another one is numpy numpy is a
python Library used for working with
arrays it also has function for working
in the domain of linear algebra and
matrices it is an open source project
you can use it freely numpy stands for
numerical python
and the third one is Phase recognition
phase recognition and manipulation using
python or the command line the easiest
facial recognition library in the world
built using Cutting Edge face
recognition technology from dlib
developed using deep learning
so moving forwards let's import our
video capture device so for that we have
to write Here video
underscore capture this is our variable
name
equals to
CV2 Dot
video
capture
and we have to pass here zero
then press enter
okay here V
should be capital
so the video capture function from
opencv is used to interact with the
cameras what we can do is video can be
re shown and saved display the image
that the camera captured
so moving forward let me import my image
for the further detection process okay
so
image equals to
FR dot load
underscore image
underscore file
then
image name or image path boy
dot jpg
press enter
using load image file we can import
image file to our detection system so
moving forward let's set encoding for
the image okay so I will write here
image underscore phase underscore
encoding
equals to
FR Dot
face
encodings
and image
then zero
press enter
yeah so face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measure to represent
the phase similar encoding would be
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so moving forward let's do let me write
first
I will write here known
encodings
equals to
image
phase
coding
okay
then press enter
then known
phase
names
equals to
then here I have to put my name so I
will write
Bank
okay then press enter
so what I did is I assigned known page
and codings to my image face encoding so
what will happen if image matches to my
face then it will print my name and for
the rest we will add name unknown okay
so let me add the function now for face
detection system
so let me write the full code for it
first then I will explain you line wise
okay
so just stay tuned with me
I will write here
so I will add while
okay true
okay so r e t comma frame I will explain
you line wise line don't worry equals to
then video
capture
dot read
and RGB
underscore frame
was to
frame
then colon
comma then again colon comma then two
colon
then minus 1.
okay
yeah
so here I will write FC underscore
locations
equals to FR dot face
underscore locations
RGB
underscore frame
right here FC FC is for basically face
encodings
plus two fr
dot face
underscore encodings
and RGB
underscore frame
comma FC underscore
locations
okay
so for
top
comma right comma
bottom
left
okay then I have to write a face
the score encoding
comma face underscore encoding this is
that was encodings this is encoding
okay so before that I will write here
Okay so
I have to write here encoding
in zip
okay then here I have to write
FC underscore
locations locations
okay
then comma then face encodings
colon
then press enter
so here I have to write matches
yeah
matches equals to FR dot compare
and faces
then known
the score phase
the score encodings
comma phase underscore encoding
okay
so
it so what if
the image will not match so I have to
give the name equals to
unknown
then we will write face distances
plus 2
FR dot phase
underscore distances
core phase
underscore encodings
comma paste
School
encoding
then I will write match underscore index
equals to NP Dot
AR
G min
okay then I will write here FC
underscore distances
yeah
then moving forward
I have light if
matches
then match underscore
index
okay then colon
then name
equals to
known underscore phase
underscore names
then
match underscore index
and I have to write here CV2
Dot rectangle
and frame
comma
comma top
comma right
to give another bracket here
comma
bottom
that comma
0 comma zero comma 255
again comma then 2 for the Border
so then CV2 dot rectangle
yeah
oh Mom then again
left comma
bottom
then minus
35.
okay
so then I will write
comma bottom
comma
then again
0 comma zero comma 255
then CV2 dot f i l l e d field
okay
F should be capital
yeah
so then we will set font equals to
CV2
Dot
font
okay
font
the score
underscore
simplex
okay
so then I have to write here
CV2
dot put
text
name
comma name
comma
left
six
comma bottom
minus six
okay then comma point
comma
1.0 then
again one comma then we have to set
location like 255
comma 255
comma 255
then comma
1.
okay
and here I have to write CV2
dot image show I am show
then like
simply learn
is detection
comma frame
and if
CV2 Dot
weight key
is 1
and
x 0 x
f
the capital f f equals to equals to
ORD then
quit
and here I will write break
I will write video
underscore capture
dot release
dv2
dot destroy
all
windows
okay yeah
so let me explain you
so in general rad is a Boolean value
that indicates whether or not there was
a even a return each frame that is
written is at the same frame if there is
no frame you will receive none rather
than an error
in opencv reading and writing videos and
reading and writing images are quite
similar a video is nothing more than a
collection of pictures often known as
frames
so to draw a rectangle around the face
that was discovered we utilize the
opencv rectangle the rectangle function
we can draw the rectangle by using the
points or Corners position that the
phase location
and
yes encoding this a face encoding this
one
so a face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measures to represent
the phase similar encoding what we
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so this there is a use compare phase
so compare phase is used to compare my
face to uploaded image one okay if it
matches it will print my name otherwise
we have given a known here
so the numpy ARG arm
this one
but it went this numpy ARG min
so the number ARG main method delivers
the indexes of the arrays minimum
element along each axis return an array
of array indices with the same shape of
the array
so this font that is yeah
font Hershey simplex
is normal size of sans serif font okay
so put text put text is used to put the
text on the frame like my name or
unknown
so in order to display an image in a
window we use the IM show this one
this I am sure function
okay so the window adjust itself to the
size of image parameters window name a
string that identifies the window in
which the displayed image will appear
okay
so until a key is pressed wait key zero
this one okay so until a key is pressed
wait key 0 will will keep the window
open it is suitable for image display
and wait key one
I write here wait key one
so wait key one will show a frame for
one Ms before closing the display on its
own
so after the script has ended users can
close or remove all the windows use the
python
like using destroy all function function
okay you would use the function if you
wanted to close a window while it was
open in numerous windows at once
so let's see our phase detection system
is working or not so let me close this
person on screen first okay
so let me close this first
let me run this
now so here you can see this pop-up and
I will open so here you can see my name
is correctly printing
okay
so
like I have uploaded my image it's
directing correctly okay
so like what if I show uh one more image
so here you can see this is my card
so it is
detecting properly
yeah
so what if I will show like another guy
image so
from my mobile
so here you can see
it is spring unknown in
Messi's photo
yeah
so what if if I will write here like uh
one of the
other image this random.jpg then it
should print unknown for me also okay
then I will run it again
okay it's working
has come
so here you can see it is now printing
unknown because like I have uploaded
that another random image here so it is
importing
okay so it is printing unknown here
so here you can see like it's spinning
unknown for me also hi everyone
and welcome to the simple and YouTube
channel
in this section we will create an OTP
verification GUI using python but before
we begin if you love watching Tech video
subscribe to our Channel like the
tutorial and hit the Bell icon to now
miss an update
and before we start I hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes and if there is
any issue do let us know in the chat
section
and let us have a simple question to
brush upon our knowledge
and please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the correct
answer in the print comment and your
question is
how is a code block indicated in Python
and your options are brackets
indentation
skin
or none of these
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section moving on
first you will see WhatsApp project and
how it looks like so
we will save it and run the program
you can see that the Tinker window has
appeared
and this is our project and this is what
we're gonna make in this video so using
twilio I have received the OTP on my
mobile phone and that is 4601
foreign
I can see the show info window that says
that the verification is successful
and we have one more window for you guys
if
you
want
you can also make it we will also
discuss this in this video
so you can see this is the first window
we will create and after we click on the
generate OTP button
it will redirect to the second window
that is verify OTP and there you could
just type in the OTP you get on your
mobile phone and the OTP I code is 6709
and I will just click on the submit
button it will show that the
verification is successful
there's a recent OTP button and there's
a timer as the twilio tokens they are
default available for 10 minutes only so
I have set up a timer for 10 minutes if
you want you can also make the timer as
you could just go with the verify OTP
GUI and the design button it will just
make that video send the OTP again to a
mobile phone so if there is any
difficulty in reaching the RDP to us
so moving on now
we will start with our project
that is first we will create a folder
and name it as OTP verification
and inside
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open the editor I would be
using the visual studio code you could
choose any editor as you like or you
have the hands on any editor
for that I will write the command code
space period and press enter
so here we will
create the name of the file as program 2
Dot py
and now we should install and import the
modules uh for tick and term we don't
have to install it like click enter is a
python module that is used to develop
GUI that is graphical user interface
there's no need to install any module as
decanter module is a part of the
standard python Library
and here we need to install twilio
so for that
we will open the command prompt and
write the command
okay install
and press enter
as it states that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed the twilio module and used it
in the project so you just have to write
the command and press enter in the
command prompt or in the terminal of
your editor
and the rest would be done for you
so moving on
we will
import the modules
so from click enter
we will
import all the classes and files
and from to video
we will import the client class
and to generate the OTP we will use the
random module and generate the
OTP with the random function
random
and we would also be using the message
box but here we will see it later on
so now we'll create a class
in the taken term
so in order to initialize the class we
use the underscore underscore init
function this creates a method that runs
itself when we form an object from the
class
so we will make a class
and name it as OTP wire verifier
OTP underscore verified
and inside you will pass TK
colon
and as I said we will
make the
init
and pass self in it
so we will create a root window and
display it on the screen for that we
will just run window dot main Loop to
pop out The Tick into window
and for that
and the slow we will just
write
to a super
yeah
foreign
provides many methods and one of them is
the geometry method this method is used
to set the dimensions of vetting enter
window and is used to set the positions
of the main window on the user's
textbook
so for that we will use the geometry
function
and write the command self
documentary
and inside the cutting places for
recycle bases
we'll set the y-axis
as 1000 course x axis with 580
and
mute
to make it shift with 200 dimensions
then y-axis
80 dimensions and the x-axis
now we will configure the window so we
will use the config function so config
and configure function they both are
same and they can be used on any widget
to change settings that you may have
applied earlier or haven't applied yet
so for that we'll write the command
self.configure
and inside we will set the background
color as white only for the tick enter
window
and use the hexa code for the colors you
could use for example or just write
White
so what might be
have
six apps you can search for the code the
extra code
or you could just write the white color
now we will use the resizable function
so this method is used to allow T print
root window to change its size according
to the user's need as well as we can
prove the resizing of your deakander
window so basically if you want to
create a fixed size window this method
can be used in resizable method user can
pass either positive integer or true to
make them into resizable but if you want
to prohibit the resizing of the window
you could just pass folds or zero
so we would just provate it
we will write the command
self Dot
peace size table
so we have provided our window
and now
before executing code python interpreter
read source file and Define few special
variables to Global variables if the
python interpreter is running the source
file as the main program it sets the
special variable that would be the
underscore underscore
name variable
as value equal to Main
that value
would be equal to underscore underscore
main if this file is being imported from
another module so the name variable will
be set to the module's name module's
name is available as value to name
variable that is the global variable
so to execute it
we'll write the command
if
name equal to Main and that
could be in line but it commas
here first we will
clause
window equal to
vertically underscore
verifier
and now
write a command click on the main Loop
that is the main thing to get a window
popped up so we'll save the file
and run it
so we go to Arrow here
so
it is due to the spaces
don't
have to Make spaces in the geometry
method
and now we'll save it and run it you can
see that the click enter window has
popped up
now
we will make its GUI and before that
we will see that value so this is the
twilio console
you have to login into that and that
would be your account Sid the token and
the phone number from which you will get
the OTP
so I will show you the demo for that
you can just visit that value
website
so 12 is an American company that is
based in the San Francisco
which provides programmable
communication tools for making and
saving phone calls sending any Sim text
messages and Performing other
communication functions using it web
service apis
so this is the website here you can just
go
sign up
as I have the account already I will
just log in in it you will just write
the first name last name email and
password that should be 16 plus
characters
and after that you will accept it and
start a free trial it doesn't need any
credit card or something you can just
use it without any payment mode and
after that it will ask you to get your
phone number assigned or it will ask
first it will ask you like what purpose
are you serving the 12 year
so you could just make it that you want
to run it for your project or any code
purpose and after that you have to
generate the phone number from which you
will get the SMS
foreign
so I have my console already I have
logged in
so
I'm going to the code part
now we'll use twilio
to get our DB
on our mobile phones
so
for that we will write the command
in the class only that is odbi file
we will use the current function for
that we will create a variable
self taught client
and that is equal to
and use the client function
and inside will pass two parameters
that would be from the console
that would be the account Sid we will
copy that
and
will paste it in the inverted commas
and the next parameter will pass
the authorized token that would be
unique for you
paste this
and
that would also bend the inverted commas
only
and next
we'll write the command serve.client dot
messages
that is we'll use the variable
above there was a client variable
and we'll create the messages
and here we will write our phone number
that
here two and equal to
and inside
the brackets we will write the contact
number
you want to receive the message
so here I am writing my contact number
and
not highlighted
as it
as I can get the Spam messages or sample
so I would not highlight it
and
we will
write the contact number that we have
got from that video
that contact number is your phone number
we will copy that
and right wrong
so from
underscore
the paste that with your phone number
comma and then the body what body we
want to receive
as a text message from this number so
the body we want to receive an OTP
so for that we will use the random
module and generate an OTP
so first we will create a variable
store it in a variable n
all right
hold that we should use the random
module to generate the OTP for that we
will just
make a function and name it as OTP only
and inside you will pass
itself
and this function we will return
foreign
range function
and pass the range
so this function will choose any number
from this range and return to us
so we will ask this function to generate
a phone number OTP
so we have
made the function
for the OTP and now we'll assign it
to the variable we have declared above
so in this variable
we will We contact the OTP should be
passed as a string
because body would take as number as a
string only
so with that will write the command
Str
ap.otp
in the body will get the variable
and only
for that we'll write the command self.n
ET
now
we will
save it
and run it
example
to is an issue here
element
would successfully executed so sometimes
it takes time okay
and now we will start with the GI GUI
and for that
it will create a function so that we can
store all the widgets there
and we will name the function as labels
and first thing we will create would be
the canvas Widget the Cano switch it
lets us display various graphics on the
application it can be used to draw
simple shapes to complicated graphs we
can also display various kinds of custom
widgets according to our needs so first
we will
create a variable
and name it as C
and inside
we will make the canvas widget
then now we'll set its background color
and then
I will use the hexa code only if you
could just
see
that's the gray color
you could use
the example or you can just write the
name of the color
or if you want you can just search on
the web you would get the hexag codes
and you would get the variations of all
the colors in hexa board and I will set
the width for the canvas and width would
be equal to
400 as you can see that it is in the
comments
we have to put the hex support in the
inverted commas
yeah
so we have set the weight and now we
will set the height
that is
280
and now
we will place this canvas for that we
will use the Place function and that
place function allows you explicitly set
the position inside of a window either
in absolute terms or relative to another
window
so for that we'll write the command self
dot C dot place
okay and the X Dimension would be equal
to 290
and Y Dimension will be equal to 120 and
now
we'll just save this
and run the file
so we have to call the
enables function also
let's save it and run it again
you could see that this is the canvas
the gray canvas
and moving on now we will create a frame
and that would also be in the labels
function so frame is a rectangular
region on the screen and that can also
be used as a foundation class to
implement complex widgets it is used to
organize a group of widgets so we will
create a upper frame and inside that we
will place a small image with OTP
verification and the heading
that would be to verify the OTP
so for that first we will create a
variable and we will name it as upper
underscore frame
and inside we will create a frame
and
the f is capital
for that same widget
and inside we will send
and set the background color
equal to Blue and that will be the W and
I will use the hexa code for that hexa
code is 4 6
a 2p4
yeah this is the color you can see here
and now we'll set its width and before
that we will
get this into the inverted commas
and I will check the width
width would be equal to 1500
and now we'll set its height
should be equal to 130
and now we will place it so we should be
in the peak enter window for that we'll
use the place function
write the command self Dot
or underscore frame
dot place
yeah
so we will
place it at x equal to zero and y equal
to 0.
so I'll save the file and run it for you
so you can see the output side by side
yeah you can see that this is the frame
and we've set the color as blue and it
we have placed it as x equal to 0 and y
equal to 0. we have created the canvas
so now moving on
we'll use the labels
and in the labels only first we will
place the image in the frame
for that uh
first I will choose the image as I have
already made the project I have chose
the images
and I have pasted it in the folder
that is picks
and
with these
and we paste it in our
project folder
so first I would be using the password
one image
and I will set it in the frame only
and in take and turn like some widgets
can display an image such as label and
button and we would be using label to
display this image and for buttons also
I have created the images as you have
seen in the folder
so I will show you how to use these
images and show them as a button so
these widgets take an image argument
that allows them to display an image
so for that we will create a variable
and name it is picture
and the widget is photo image
and inside you have to pass the location
of the file where the image is stored
so we have just placed it in the same
folder so we'll just write the name of
the image and that was
password
one
there was no spaces and that was the PNG
file
yeah
after creating a photo image object you
can use it
you can use it with other widgets that
accept an eatman's argument
the image object is returned by the
photo image function that we have used
and it's that easy to display a picture
in Python however the photo image class
only supports the GIF and PGM PPM
formats which is a concern
jpeg jpg and PNG are the formats that
are most often used
so now
we will place the image in the frame
for that
first create a label for that and
we will create a variable and name it is
K
and create a label widget
antique inter label is a widget that is
used to implement display boxes where
you can place text or images so here we
would be first placing the image and
then the text so inside the label widget
and we'll pass the argument that goes
the variable for the upper frame and
then the image object
foreign
set the background
as the same as of the frame for that we
will write BG
equal to and the hexa good
that is same that is four six eight two
B four
and now we will place it
so write the command here only
that is Dot
place
and X
would be equal to 200
what meter could be 220
and y equal to 35.
and
save this and run the file
foreign
so now we will write verify
OTP and we will also create the labels
for that
first will close
now inside the label function only
we will create another label
for the text and first we will create a
variable and name it as J
and inside we will create a label widget
and
inside the upper frame
write a text
that would be verify OTP
set the font for it
that b friends to Roman
you could also
set the size as 38 and make them bold
and now we'll set the background color
for that
that will in the inverted commas and
that would be the blue only for that
we'll write the hexa code
there was four six eight two B four
and now we will set the foreground color
that would be the text color as white
and here we will notice the hexagon I
would write the name of the color
for that we'll write the command
foreground color
that is equal to White
and now we'll place this label
please add
around 270
and Y would be same
and that would be 35 only
now let's save this and run the file
we have get the label verify OTP but
they both are insideing so we will just
change the coordinates
for this label
and we'll set as
320
300.
save the file
close the
previous decanter window
save the file and run it
actually I just got home so you can see
that it has shown the verify OTP but
still it's not in the center so we will
just again change the export image for
that and that would be
400
we will save the file
and run it
could see that
now it is in the center
to place it accordingly like I would be
creating the GUI and if you want
Perfection you can do that by one
and now moving on we will place a simply
learned image
just on the file and show you like where
we
will place a simple line image
you have a place and just write the
bottom right
before that we will create the label
again and first
we'll use the photo image to create the
photo object go to image object and
first we'll create the variable
and name it is simply
underscore logo
and inside we'll use the photo image
then write the name of the file
I also to write the location of the file
as we have the files in the folder only
and we have the simply learn file with
the name simply learn
space logo
so just use the file name
you should check that this okay
yeah
that's it
so write the name of the file
so that is still building line space
no
and the extension of the file is
PNG
and now create a label for the photo
image object
for that we will create another variable
and name it as e
use the label widget
handle password and
image equal to
self Dot
simply done
yes
no more
and we'll set the foreground color
equal to White and for that will use the
hexa code for white color
and now
we'll paste this label
at X
equal to 870
that would be the bottom right
and why
by 30.
it's showing an error
okay we have used the image name here we
have to use the variable
that is simply underscore logo
so now
let's save this
close to previous
click into window
and run the file
okay
[Music]
um
victim from spelling
for the image file
download
and then run it
takes time to open up
you can see that the simple logo has
been placed at the bottom right
now moving on
okay I will
show you what we will execute next
so we will place an
text widget here in which we can just
enter the OTP and after that we will
make the buttons verify OTP and the
recent ODB first we'll
make the text in which we will write our
DP
so for that
we won't make it in the labels function
so that will create another function
and if it is entry
we will enter the video
and
make a variable that would be username
and use the text widget so text widget
is used that a user wants to insert
multi-line text Fields this widget can
be used for a variety of applications
where the multi-line text is required
such as messaging sending information or
displaying information and many other
tasks we can insert media files such as
images and links also in the text widget
and for that
for to enter the OTP we will create the
next widget and
we will write text
and inside
self
and now we'll set the font size in which
you would enter the OTP and it would set
it as calibery
and the size to the font would be 20.
and no
let's check the Border width
for the text
so it should have a border width so we
could see on that canvas
and we'll use wrap
so if
the word
put that text it exceeds the width of
the text widget it will just wrap it and
send it to the next line
and
exactly right word
and set the width
equal to
23
and height
equal to 1
and now we will place it
and we'll paste it in the canvas that
was of the gray color so that will write
the command
self dot the variable name user
underscore
name and we will place it
okay x equal to 330
and y equal to 200.
save the file and run it and see whether
text wizard has been created
successfully or not and before that we
have to run this function
Mouse entry
save this and run the file
that you can download oh it's already
okay
okay import an error
okay and we are not
for the font
want equal to calibrary we will save
this and run again
yeah it has appeared so this is the text
widget in which we will write our OTP
and verify it now we'll make the submit
button and the resend automate button
and write the functionalities for it
so the pattern widget is used to add
various types of buttons to the python
application python allows us to
configure the look of the button
according to our requirements and for
that we'll create a function
patents and we'll try to hold the
buttons here that would be two buttons
only
that is submit and check node
will check the RDP
the second return would be the send OTP
and first we will create a variable for
the summit button image
we'll create the submit button first
we'll create a variable
and limit as submit button
and first we will
assign the image to that button
we already have this submit image in our
folder
we will use this image
called photo image
sorry
it's going to call the photo image
and inside we will pass the file
address and
if I use submit.pn
and now
the photo image object has been created
so we'll create the submit button
will create a variable
as the name of submit button only
and
to make a button we'll use the pattern
widget and inside the first parts
self and then the image that should be
appeared
and that would be equal to the variable
name that is submit button image
okay and now we'll set the command so
command is used to call the function
so what function does this button do
that would be stored in the command
and that would be equal to we will name
the function as check OTP as submit
return mode check the OTP only
we'll create this function
after this pattern only
and now
we will set the Border
then
we won't make the word of we will set it
as zero here
now we will place the submit button
for that we will write the command serve
to it submit button
the place and
X would be equal to 440 and by equal to
330
and now we will start with the resend
button
please send OTP button
and after that we will create the
checkout review function
so for the recent OTB button first we
will create the photo image object
that we will write a variable
it's end
4 DB
that P
um
image
and pass the file name
this words
space and OTP dot PNG
now we'll create the button
so that will write the command cell
don't descend
OTP variable
and use the button widget
and inside pass self
and then the image that will be set as
the button image
that would be equal to the variable name
of the
photo image object
that is this and
OTP image
okay
okay oh yeah
make sure you know
so I'm going to be an image but
okay
Mr coma
yeah
now we will set the command
and that would be the function
that will store the functionalities that
this button will do
and name the function as
we send OTP only
and call that would also use help as
pass the cells there
and that would be applicable to check
out okay also
and now let's set the coder
equal to zero
for the reason OTP
image and now we will paste it
and we'll place it at 420 comma 430.
so that would write the command
itself Dot
please send OTP
Windows please
and set x equal to 420
and Y
equal to 430
no both the buttons have been made
and here I'm going to
buttons
save the file and run it
so it's saying that the check OTP
that's what I attribute here
so first we'll create those functions
only check OTP and the recent OTP
foreign
so first we will create the recent OTP
function
so connect
and inside
we will paste the same as
we just write the commands to get the
OTP
these other ones
let it pasted
so this is the index and OTP function
now we'll create the checkout DB
function
so that
will write
function name that is check OTP
and password to that
and inside
you can use try
so if any exception occurs we would get
it easily solved
and here we will create the variable
with any user input
and get it stored in integer value
so it will convert the text Network
string which have passed as the body so
it will
take the text and convert it into
integer
send input
that value from the user underscore name
you would be writing the OTP there only
there
now we will create some conditions to
check if the OTP is correct so we will
get the message box popped out
and put that we'll write the command if
serve to user input
is equal to equal to
integer value of self.n
then we will make the message spoked out
and we will import the message box
class also
as we have already imported all the
classes from the tech intern but again
we will import it
and if this condition goes through
we want a message box
to show info
and inside we have to paths the shown
for
and
we will make it as verification
successful
you could write anything like the OTP is
verified
and write verification successful
and
no
if
self Dot and
where to done
so the OTP would be done there
else
would also pop out the message box and
for that we'll write the command message
box
to join form
and inside we will pass the variables
showing for and
we will get the indication as strong OTP
no
we will make the exception here as we
will start right Loop you have to use
the accept block also and here also we
will use the messages only
inside will pass
that's good
tell us invalid OTP
and here we will import a message box
so that will write the command
from Taken to import message box
foreign
now
I will save the file
and run it
thank you
okay
now we'll save the file and run it
as you can see that the decanter window
has popped up and I have received the
OTP on my mobile phone that is one eight
five six
and I will click on the submit button
so it's showing from OTP
yeah we will resend it
and go to the new DPS 2851
click on the submit button it says that
the verification is successful so we
have made the verification OTP
GUI successfully and you could add that
timer also in it
for that I will just copy paste the code
for the timer
I will also provide the source file in
the description if you want you can see
there
code
if you want to know how the timer is
made
you could just see or another video in
the description or on the I button
just copy paste the code
so this is the runtime of function
so you can see that the timer has
started and it's for the 10 minutes as
12 Leo default tokens are valid only for
10 minutes
and
received another OTP we will resend it
again
and it's 7848
you click on the submit button it says
that the verification is successful and
if you want to make the first page
you can see the source code
I will make it available for you guys
I will make
file that would be program.py
clicking images program one dot py
foreign
class and imported the program 2 module
and we have installed the module sub
processes and we are calling the import
class
and here we have made the class generate
OTP
and inside we have set the geometry and
configured the color as white for the
first window and we have made it
that the window could not be resizable
that's why we have passed
the folds and false arguments to the
resizable
function
and here we have created the labels
as you would see in the
first window and the button generate OTP
so we will save the file
and run it
first we'll call this
yes
now we'll save it
and run the file
for the simply learn logo
so the file name is
I will replace that
save it and run it again see the first
window that is
OTP verification and
OTP is ready for 10 minutes and click on
the generate OTB button generate OTP
I'll click on generate OTP button
and it would
redirect to the second page that is
verifiable tipping so we have done with
the project
with that we have come to the end of
this session I hope it was interesting
and informative if you liked it please
let us know in the comment section below
also do subscribe to our Channel and
stay tuned for more from Simply love
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here